the following is a conversation with
daniel schmucktenberger
a founding member of the consilience
project that is aimed at improving
public sense-making and dialogue
he's interested in understanding how we
humans
can be the best version of ourselves as
individuals and as
collectives at all scales quick mention
of our sponsors
ground news netsuite four sigmatic
magic spoon and better help check them
out in the description to support this
podcast
as a side note let me say that i got a
chance to talk to daniel on and off the
mic
for a couple of days we took a long walk
the day before our conversation
i really enjoyed meeting him just on a
basic human level we talked about the
world
around us with words that carried hope
for us individual ants
actually contributing something of value
to the colony
these conversations are the reasons i
love human beings our insatiable
striving
to lessen the suffering in the world but
more than that
there's a simple magic to two strangers
meeting for the first time
and sharing ideas becoming fast friends
and creating something that is far
greater than the sum
of our parts i've gotten to experience
some of that same magic here in austin
with a few new friends and in random
bars in my travels across this country
where a conversation leaves me with a
big stupid smile on my face
and a new appreciation of this too short
too beautiful life
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation
with daniel schmuckenberger if aliens
were observing earth through the entire
history
just watching us and uh we're tasked
with uh summarizing what happened until
now
what do you think they would say what do
you think they would write up in that
summary
like it has to be pretty short less than
a page
like in uh hitchhiker's guide
there's i think like a paragraph or a
couple sentences how would you
summarize how sorry how would the aliens
summarize do you think
uh all of human civilization my
first thoughts take more than a page
they'd probably distill it
because if they watched well i mean
first
i have no idea if their senses are even
attuned to similar stuff to what our
senses are attuned to
or what the nature of their
consciousness is like relative to ours
and
so let's assume that they're kind of
like us just technologically more
advanced to get here from wherever they
are
that's the first kind of constraint on
the thought experiment
and then if they've watched throughout
all of history
they saw the burning of alexandria they
saw that 2000 years ago
in greece we were producing things like
clocks the anti-catherine mechanism and
then that technology got lost they saw
that there wasn't just a steady
dialectic of progress
so every once in a while there's a giant
fire that destroys a lot of things
there's a giant like
uh commotion that destroys a lot of
things
yeah and it's usually self-induced
uh they would have seen seen that and so
as they're looking at us now as we move
past the nuclear
weapons age into the full globalization
anthropocene
exponential tech age still making our
decisions relatively similarly to how we
did
um in the stone age as far as rivalry
game theory type stuff i
i think they would think that this is
probably most likely one of the planets
that is not going to make it to being
intergalactic because we blow ourselves
up in the technological adolescence
and if we are going to we're going to
need some
major progress rapidly in the
social technologies that can guide and
bind and direct the physical
technologies
so that we are safe vessels for the
amount of power we're getting
actually hitchhiker's guide has uh
estimation about how
how much of a risk this particular thing
poses to the rest of the galaxy and i
think
i forget what it was i think it was
medium or low
so so their estimation was would be that
this this species of ant-like creatures
is not going to survive long
there's ups and downs in terms of
technological innovation
the fundamental nature of their behavior
from a game theory perspective hasn't
really changed
they have not learned in any fundamental
way how to
control and properly incentivize
or properly do the mechanism design
of games to ensure long-term survival
and then they move on to not the planet
do you uh think there is
in a more slightly more serious question
do you think
there's some number or perhaps a very
very large number
of uh intelligent alien civilizations
out there
yes would be hard to think otherwise i
know
i think posturum had a new article not
that long ago on why that might not be
the case that
the drake equation might not be the kind
of in story on it
but when i look at the total number of
kepler planets just
that we're aware of just galactically
and and also
like when that um when those life forms
were discovered in mono lake
that didn't have the same six primary
atoms i think it had arsenic replacing
phosphorus as one of the
primary aspects of its energy metabolism
we get to think about that the building
blocks might be
more different so the physical
constraints even the planets have to
have might be more different
uh it seems really unlikely not
not to mention interesting things that
we've observed
that are still unexplained as you've had
guests on your show discussing tic tac
and oh oh the ones that have visited
yeah well let's dive right into that
what do you make sense of
the rich human psychology of uh there
being
hundreds of thousands probably millions
of witnesses of ufos of different kinds
on earth
most of which i presume are conjured up
by the human mind
through the perception system some
number
might be true some number might be
reflective of
actual physical objects whether it's uh
you know drones or testing military
technology that's secret or
otherworldly technology we make sense of
all of that
because it's gained quite a bit of
popularity recently
there's uh some sense in which that's um
that's us humans being hopeful and
dreaming
of otherworldly creatures
as a way to escape the dreariness of our
of the human condition but in another
sense it could be
it really could be something truly
exciting that a science should
turn its eye towards so what do you
where do you place it speaking of
turning eye towards this is one of those
super fascinating actually super
consequential possibly
topics that i wish i had more time to
study and just haven't allocated so i
i don't have firm beliefs on this
because i haven't got to study it as
much as i want so what i'm going to say
comes from a superficial assessment
um while we know there are plenty of
things that people thought of as ufo
sightings that we can fully
write off we have other better
explanations for them
uh what we're interested in is the ones
that we don't have better explanations
for and then not just immediately
jumping to
a theory of what it is but holding it as
unidentified and being
being curious and earnest i think the
the tic tac one is quite interesting and
made it in major media recently but
i don't know if you ever saw the
disclosure project a guy named steven
greer organized
a bunch of mostly us military and some
commercial
flight people who had
direct observation and classified
information uh disclosing it at a cnn
briefing
and so you saw high-ranking generals
admirals fighter pilots all describing
things that they saw
on radar with visual uh
with their own eyes or cameras and also
describing some
phenomena that had some consistency
across different
people and i find this interesting
enough that
i think it would be silly to just
dismiss it um
and specifically like we can we can ask
the question
how much of it is natural phenomena ball
lightning or something like that
and this is why i'm more interested in
what uh fighter pilots and astronauts
and people who are trained
in being able to
identify uh flying objects and um
atmospheric phenomena have to say about
it
i think the thing then you you could say
well are they
more advanced military craft is it some
kind of
you know human craft the interesting
thing that a number of them describe is
something that's kind of like
right angles at speed or not right
angles acute angles at speed
but something that looks like a
different relationship to inertia than
physics makes sense for us
i don't think that there are any human
technologies that are doing that even in
really deep
uh underground black projects now
one could say okay well could it be a
hologram well would it show up on radar
if radar is also seeing it
and so uh i don't know i think there's
enough
i mean and for that to be a massive
coordinated psyop
is it as interesting and
ridiculous in a way as the idea that
it's ufos
from some extra planetary source so
it's up there on the interesting topics
to me there
if it is at all alien technology it is
the
dumbest version of alien technology
it's so far away it's like the old old
crappy vhs
tapes of alien technology these are like
crappy drones that just floated
or even like space to the level of like
space junk
because it is so close to our human
technology
we talk about it moves in ways that's uh
that's unlike
what we understand about physics but it
still has very similar
kind of geometric notions
and something that we humans can
perceive with our eyes all those kinds
of things i feel like
alien technology most likely would be
something that
we would not be able to perceive not
because they're hiding but because it's
so far advanced
that it would be much
it would be beyond the cognitive
capabilities of us humans just as you
were saying
as per your answer for aliens
summarizing earth
it's uh the starting assumption is they
have similar perception
systems they have similar cognitive
capabilities and
that very well may not be the case let
me ask you about
staying in aliens for just a little
longer because i think it's a good
transition
talking about governments and human
societies
do you think if a u.s government
or any government was in possession
of an alien spacecraft or of information
related to alien spacecraft they would
have the capacity structurally would
they have
the the processes
would they be able to uh
communicate that to the public
effectively or would they keep it secret
in the room
and do nothing with it both of uh to try
to preserve
military secrets but also because of the
incompetence that's inherent to
bureaucracies
or either
we can certainly see when certain things
become declassified 25 or 50 years later
that there were things that the public
might have wanted to know
that were kept secret for a very long
time for reasons of
at least supposedly national security um
which is also a nice source of plausible
deniability for
um people covering their ass for doing
things that would be problematic um
other purposes
there are there's a scientist at
stanford
who supposedly um got some material that
was
recovered from area 51 type area did
analysis on it using i believe electron
microscopy and a couple
other methods and came to the idea that
it was a nanotech alloy
um that was something we didn't
currently have the ability to do was not
naturally occurring
so there i've heard some things and
again like i said i'm not going to stand
behind any of these because i haven't
done the level of study to have high
confidence um
i think what you said also about would
it be super low-tech alien
craft like would they necessarily move
their atoms around in space
or might they do something more
interesting than that might they be able
to
uh have a different relationship to the
concept of space or
information or consciousness or um
one of the things that the craft
supposedly do is not only
accelerate and turn in a way that looks
non-inertial but also disappear
so there's a question as to like the two
are not necessarily mutually exclusive
and it could be possible to some people
run a hypothesis
that they create intentional amounts of
exposure as an invitation
of a particular kind um
who knows interesting field we tend to
assume
like seti that's listening out for
aliens out there
i've just been recently reading more and
more about gravitational waves and you
have
orbiting black holes that orbit each
other
they generate ripples in space time
on my uh for fun at night when i lay in
bed i think about what it would be like
to ride those waves
when they not not the low magnitude they
are as it when they reach earth but
get closer to the black holes because
they'll basically be shrinking
and expanding us in all dimensions
including time so it's actually
ripples through space time that they
generate
why is it that you couldn't use that
it travels the speed of light
travels that it's a very weird thing to
say when you're
when you're uh morphing space-time it's
it's a comp it's it's
you could argue it's faster than the
speed of light
so if you're able to communicate by
to someone enough energy to generate
black holes and to orbit the
uh to force them to orbit each other why
not
travel as the ripples
in space-time whatever the hell that
means
somehow combined with wormholes so if
you're able to communicate through
like we don't think of uh gravitational
waves that's something you can
communicate with
because the the radio will be have to be
the side
a very large size and very dense but
perhaps that's it
you know perhaps that's one way to
communicate it's a very effective way
and that would explain
like we wouldn't even be able to make
sense of that of the physics that
results
in an alien species that's able to
control gravity at that scale
i think you just jumped up the kardashev
scale so far
you're not just harnessing the power of
a star but harnessing the power
of mutually rotating black holes um
i i that's way above my physics pay
grade to think about including
even uh non-rotating black hole versions
of trans warp travel
um i think
you know you can talk with eric more
about that i think he has better ideas
on it than i do
my hope for the future of humanity
mostly does not
rest in the near term on our ability to
get to other habitable planets
in time and even more than that in the
list of possible solutions of uh how to
improve human civilization
uh orbiting black holes is not in the on
the first page for you
and not on the first page okay i bet you
did not expect us to start this
conversation here
but i'm glad the places it went
i am excited on a much smaller scale of
uh mars europa or titan
or venus potentially having very
like bacteria like life forms just on a
on a small human level it's a little bit
scary but mostly really exciting
that there might be life elsewhere in
the volcanoes and the oceans
all around us teaming having little
societies
and whether there's properties about
that kind of life
that's somehow different than ours i
don't know would be more exciting if
those colonies of single cell type
organisms
what would be more exciting if they're
different or they're the same
if they're the same that means
through the rest of the universe there's
life forms
like us something like us
everywhere if they're different that's
also really exciting because there's
life forms everywhere they're not like
us
that's a little bit scary i don't know
what's scary actually
i think both scary and exciting no
matter what right
the idea that they could be very
different is philosophically very
interesting for us to open our
aperture on what life and consciousness
and
and self-replicating possibilities could
look like
the question on are they different or
the same obviously there's lots of life
here that is
the same in some ways and different in
other ways um
when you take the thing that we call an
invasive species is something that's
still pretty the same hydrocarbon based
thing
but co-evolved with co-selective
pressures in a certain environment we
move it to another environment it might
be devastating to that whole
ecosystem because it's just different
enough that it messes up the
self-stabilizing
dynamics of that ecosystem so the
question of
are they would they be different
in ways where we could still figure out
a way to inhabit a biosphere together
or fundamentally not fundamentally the
uh
nature of how they operate and the
nature of how we operate would be
incommensurable is a deep question well
we offline talked about
mimetic theory right it seems like
if there were sufficiently different
where we would not even we can coexist
on different planes
uh it seems like a a good thing if we're
close enough
together to where we'd be competing then
it's you're getting into the world of
viruses and pathogens and all those
kinds of things
to where we would uh one of us would die
off quickly
through basically mass murder
without even even accidentally
even accidentally if we just had a
self-replicating single-celled kind of
creature
that happened to
not work well for the hydrocarbon life
that was here that god introduced
because it either output something that
was toxic or utilized up the same
resource too quickly and it just
replicated faster and mutated faster
it wouldn't be a um memetic theory
conflict theory kind of harm it would
just be uh
a von neumann machine a self-replicating
machine that was
fundamentally incompatible with these
kinds of self-replicating systems
with faster ooda loops for one final
time putting your alien
slash god hat on and you look at human
civilization
the do you think uh about the 7.8
billion people on earth
as individual little creatures
individual little organisms
or do you think of us as uh
one organism with the collective
intelligence
what's the proper framework through
which to analyze it
again as an alien so that i know where
you're coming from would you have asked
the question the same way
before the industrial revolution before
the agricultural revolution when there
were half a billion people and no
telecommunications connecting them
i would indeed ask the question the same
way but i would be less confident about
uh about your conclusions
um it would be an actually more
interesting way to ask the question at
that time but i was nevertheless asked
it the same way
yes well let's go back further and
smaller then
rather than just a single human or the
entire human species let's look at
uh in a relatively isolated tribe
yes in the relatively isolated probably
sub dunbar number sub
150 people tribe do i look at that
as one entity where evolution is
selecting for based on group selection
or do i think of it as 150 individuals
that are interacting in some way
well could those individuals exist
without the group
no the
evolutionary adaptiveness of humans
was involved critically group selection
and
individual humans alone trying to figure
out stone tools and protection and
whatever
uh aren't what was selected for
and so i think the ore is the wrong
frame i think it's
individuals are affecting the
group that they're a part of they're
also dependent upon and being affected
by the group that they're part of
and so this now starts to get in deep
into political theories
also which is theories that orient
towards the collective at different
scales whether a tribal scale or an
empire or nation state or something
and ones that orient towards the
individual liberalism and stuff like
that and i think there's very obvious
failure modes on both sides
and so the relationship between them is
more interesting to me than either of
them the relationship between the
individual and the collective and the
question around how to have a virtuous
process between those so
a good social system would be one where
the organism of the individual and the
organism
of the group of individuals is they're
both synergistic to each other so what
is best for the individuals and what's
best for the whole is aligned
but there is nevertheless an individual
they're not it's uh it's a matter of
degrees i suppose but
what is uh what defines a human
more the the social
network within the which they've been
brought up
through which they've developed their
intelligence or is it their
own sovereign individual self
like what's your intuition of how much
not just for
evolutionary survival but as
intellectual beings how much do we need
others
for our development yeah i think we have
a weird sense of this today
relative to most previous periods of
sapient history
i think the vast majority of sapient
history is tribal
like depending upon your early
human model two or three hundred
thousand years of
homo sapiens and little tribes where
they depended upon that tribe for
survival and excommunication from the
tribe was
was fatal i think they and our whole
evolutionary genetic history is in that
environment and the amount of time we've
been out of it is
is relatively so tiny and then
we still depended upon extended families
and local communities more
and the big kind of giant market complex
where
i can provide something to the market to
get money to be able to get other things
from the market where it seems like i
don't need anyone it's almost like
disintermediating our sense of need even
though
even though you're in my ability to talk
to each other
using these mics and the phones that we
coordinated on took millions of people
over six continents to be able to run
the supply chains it made all the stuff
that we depend on but we don't notice
that we depend upon them they all seem
fungible
um if you take a baby obviously that you
didn't even get to a baby without a mom
was it dependent
or dependent upon each other right
without two two parents at minimum and
they depended upon other people
but if we take that baby and we put it
out in the wild it obviously dies
so if we let it grow up for a little
while the minimum amount of time where
it starts to have some autonomy and then
we put it out in the wild and if this
has happened a few times
it doesn't learn language and
it doesn't learn the artic the small
motor articulation
that we learn it doesn't learn the
type of consciousness that we end up
having that is socialized
so i think i think we take for granted
how much conditioning affects us um
is it possible that uh
it affects basically 99.9
or maybe the whole thing the whole thing
is the connection between us humans
and that were we're uh no better than
apes
without our human connections because
that
that thinking of it that way
forces us to think very differently
about human society and how to progress
forward
if the connections are fundamental i
just
have to object to the no better than
apes because better here i think you
mean a specific thing which means have
capacities that are fundamentally
different then i think apes also depend
upon
troops um yes and
i i think the idea of humans as better
than
nature in some kind of um ethical sense
ends up having heaps of problems we'll
table that we can come back to it but we
say what is unique about homo sapien
capacity relative to the other animals
we currently
inhabit the biosphere with and i'm
saying it that way because there were
other early hominids that had some of
these capacities
we believe our tool creation and our
language creation and our coordination
are all kind of the results
of a certain type of capacity for
abstraction
and other animals will use tools but
they don't evolve the tools they use
they keep using the same types of tools
that they basically can find
so a chimp will notice that a rock can
cut a vine that it wants to and it'll
even notice that a sharper rock will cut
it better
and experientially it'll use the sharper
rock and if you even give it a knife
it'll probably use the knife because
it's experiencing the effectiveness
but it doesn't make stone tools because
that requires understanding why one is
sharper than the other what is the
abstract
principle called sharpness to then be
able to invent a sharper thing
that same abstraction makes language and
the ability for abstract representation
which makes the ability to coordinate in
a more
advanced set of ways so i do think our
ability to coordinate with each other is
pretty fundamental to the selection of
what we are
as a species i wonder if that
coordination that connection
is actually the thing that gives birth
to consciousness that gives birth to
well let's start with self awareness
more like theory of mind
theory of mind yeah you know i i i
suppose there's experiments that show
that
there's other mammals that have a very
crude theory of mind
i'm not sure maybe dogs something like
that but actually dogs probably has to
do with that they co-evolved with humans
see it'd be interesting if that theory
of mind is what leads
to consciousness in the way we think
about it
is the richness of the subjective
experience that is consciousness
i have a inkling sense that that only
exists because we're social creatures
that that doesn't come uh with this with
the hardware and the software any in the
beginning
that's like uh that's learned
as an effective uh tool for
communication almost like we we think
we i think we think uh that
consciousness is fundamental
and uh maybe it's not
there's a a bunch of folks kind of
criticize the idea that the
illusion of consciousness is
consciousness that
it is just a facade we use to
to uh help us construct theories of mind
you almost put yourself in the world
as a subjective being and that
experience you want to
richly experience it as an individual
person so that i could
empathize with your experience i find
that notion compelling
mostly because it allows you to then
create robots
that become conscious not by being quote
unquote conscious but by
just learning to fake it till they make
it
is uh creative you know present a facade
of consciousness
and with the with the task of uh making
that facade
very convincing to us humans and thereby
it will become conscious
have a sense ins that in some way
that will make them conscious if they're
sufficiently
convincing to humans
is there some element of that that you
uh
do you find convincing this is a
much harder set of questions
and deep end of the pool than starting
with the aliens was
um we went from aliens to consciousness
this is not the trajectory i was
expecting nor you
but let us walk a while we we can walk a
while and i don't think we will
do it justice so what do we mean by
consciousness versus conscious
self-reflective
awareness what do we mean by awareness
qualia
theory of mind there's a lot of terms
that we think of as slightly
different things and um
subjectivity first person
i don't remember exactly the quote but i
remember when
reading when sam harris wrote the book
free will and then dennett critiqued it
and then there was some writing back and
forth between the two because normally
they're on the same side
of kind of arguing for critical thinking
and
logical fallacies and philosophy of
science against um supernatural ideas
and here dennett believed there is
something like free will he is a
determinist compatibilist but no
consciousness an ex a radical
limitativist
and sam was saying no there is
consciousness but there's no free will
and that's like the most
fundamental kinds of axiomatic senses
they disagreed on but neither of them
could say it was because the other one
didn't understand the philosophy of
science
or logical fallacies and and they kind
of spoke past each other and at the end
if i remember correctly sam said
something that i thought was quite
insightful which was to the effect of it
seems it
because they weren't making any progress
in shared understanding it seems that we
simply have different intuitions about
this
and what you could see was that
what the words meant right at the level
of symbol grounding
might be quite different one of them
might have had
deeply different enough life experiences
that what is being referenced and then
also different associations of what the
words mean this is why
when trying to address these things
charles sanders purse said the first
philosophy has to be semiotics
because if you don't get semiotics right
we end up importing different ideas and
bad ideas right into the nature of the
language that we're using
and then it's very hard to do
epistemology or ontology together
uh so i'm saying this to say why i don't
think we're gonna get very far is i
think we would have to
go very slowly in terms of defining what
we mean by
words and fundamental concepts well and
also allowing our minds to drift
together for time so that our
definitions of these terms
align i think there's some
there's a beauty that some people enjoy
with sam
that he is quite stubborn
on his definitions of terms without
often clearly revealing that definition
so in his mind he can
like you could sense that he can deeply
understand what he means
exactly by term like free will and
consciousness and you're right he's very
he's very specific in in fascinating
ways that
not only does he think that free will is
an illusion
he thinks he's able not thinks he says
he's able to just remove himself from
the experience of free will
and just be like for minutes at a time
hours at a time like
really experience as if he has no free
will like he's a
leaf flowing down the river
and given that he's very sure that
consciousness is fundamental
so here's a this conscious leaf that's
subjectively experiencing the floating
and yet there's no ability to control
and make any decisions for its
for itself it's only a um
the decisions have all been made
there's some aspect to which the
terminology there perhaps is the problem
so that's a particular kind of
meditative experience and
the people in the vedantic tradition and
some of the buddhist traditions
thousands of years ago described similar
experiences and somewhat similar
conclusions
some slightly different there are other
types of phenomenal experience
that uh are the phenomenal experience of
pure agency
and you know like the the catholic
theologian
but evolutionary theorist terra
deshardon describes this
and that rather than a creator agent god
in the beginning there's a creative
impulse or a creative process
and he was would go into a type of
meditation that identified as the pure
essence of that kind of creative process
and i think the types of experiences
we've had and then one the types of
experience we've had make a big deal to
the nature of how we do symbol grounding
the other thing is the types of
experiences we have can't not
be interpreted through our existing
interpretive frames
and most of the time our interpretive
frames are unknown even to us some of
them
and so so this is a tricky
this is a tricky topic um so i guess
there's a bunch of directions we could
go with it but i want to come back to
what the
um impulse was that was interesting
around what is consciousness and how
does it relate to us
as social beings and how does it relate
to
the possibility of consciousness with it
ais right
you're keeping us on track which is uh
which is wonderful
you're a wonderful hiking partner okay
yes let's go back to the initial impulse
of uh what is consciousness and how does
the social impulse connected
consciousness is consciousness a
consequence of that social connection
i'm gonna state a position and not argue
it because it's honestly
like it's a long hard thing to argue and
we can totally do it another time if you
want
i don't subscribe to consciousness as an
emergent property
of biology or neural networks
obviously a lot of people do obviously
the
the philosophy of science orients um
towards that
in not absolutely but
largely um
i think of the nature of first person
the universe of first person of of
qualia
as uh experience
sensation desire emotion phenomenology
the but
the felt sense not the we we say emotion
and we think of a neurochemical pattern
or an endocrine pattern
but all of the physical stuff the third
person stuff has
position and momentum and charge and
stuff like that that is
measurable repeatable i think of the
nature of first person and third person
as ontologically orthogonal to each
other
not reducible to each other they're
different kinds of stuff
and so i think about the evolution of
third person that we're quite
used to thinking about from subatomic
particles to atoms to molecules to
on and on i think about a similar kind
of and corresponding evolution in the
domain of first person from
the way whitehead talked about kind of
prehension or proto-qualia
in earlier phases of self-organization
into higher orders of it and that
there's
correspondence but that neither like the
like the idealists do we reduce third
person to first person which is what
idealists do
or neither like the physical lists or do
we reduce first person to third person
obviously baum talked about uh
an implicat order that was deeper then
and gave rise to the explicat order of
both
um nagel talks about something like that
i have a slightly different
sense of that but again i'll just kind
of not argue how that occurs for a
moment and say
so rather than say does consciousness
emerge from
i'll talk about do higher capacities of
consciousness
emerge in relationship with so it's not
first person as a category emerging from
third person but increased complexity
within the nature of first person and
third person co-evolving
um do i think that it seems relatively
likely that more advanced neural
networks have
deeper phenomenology more complex where
it goes just from
basic sensation to emotion to
social awareness to abstract cognition
to self-reflexive abstract cognition
yeah
but i wouldn't say that's the emergence
of consciousness i would say it's
increased complexity within the domain
of first person corresponding to
increased complexity
and the correspondence should not
automatically be seen as causal
we can get into the arguments for why
that often is the case
so would i say that obviously the
sapien brain is pretty unique and
a single sapient now has that right even
if it took
sapiens evolving in tribes based on
group selection to make that brain
so the group made it now that brain is
there now if i take the
single person with that brain out of the
group and try to raise them in a box
they'll still not be very interesting
even with the brain
but the brain does give hardware
capacities that if conditioned in
relationship um can have interesting
things emerge so do i think that
the the human biology
types of human consciousness and types
of social interaction
all co-emerged and co-evolved yes
as a small aside as you're talking about
the biology let me comment that i spent
this is what i do this is what i do with
my life this is why i will never
accomplish anything as i spent
much of the morning trying to calc
trying to
do research on how many computations the
brain performs and how many um
how much energy it uses versus the
state-of-the-art cpus and gpus
now arriving at uh about 20 quadrillion
so that's two to the 10 to the 16
computations so
synaptic firings per second that the
brain does
and that's about a million times faster
than the uh
uh the let's say the 20 thread
state of the arts intel cpu the uh
the 10th generation and then there's
similar calculation for the for the uh
for the gpu and all ended up also trying
to compute that it takes
10 watts to run the brain about and then
what does that mean in terms of calories
per day kilocalories
that's about to fit for an average
uh human brain that's 250 to 300
calories a day
and so it ended up being a calculation
where you're doing about
20 quadrillion calculations
uh that that are fueled by something
like depending on your diet
three bananas so three bananas results
in uh in a computation that's about a
million times
more powerful than the current stadiak
computers
now let's take that one step further
there's some assumptions built in there
the assumption is that one what the
brain is doing is
just computation two the the
relevant computations or synaptic
firings and that there's nothing other
than synaptic firings that we have to
to factor so um
i'm forgetting his name right now
there's a very uh
famous neuroscientist at stanford just
passed away recently who
did a lot of the pioneering work on
glial cells and
showed that his assessment glial cells
did a huge amount of the thinking
not just neurons and it opened up this
entirely different field of like what
the brain is and what consciousness is
you look at demacio's work on embodied
cognition and how much of what
we would consider consciousness or
feeling is happening outside of the
nervous system completely
happening in endocrine process involving
lots of other cells and signal
communication
you talk to somebody like penrose who
you've had on the show and even though
the penrose hammerhoff
conjecture's probably not right is there
something like that that might be the
case where we're actually having to look
at stuff happening at the level of
quantum computation of microtubules
i'm not arguing for any of those i'm
arguing that
we don't know how big the unknown
unknown set is
well at the very least this is this has
become like an infomercial for the human
brain
at the very but wait there's more
at the very least the three bananas buys
you a million times that's the very last
that's very
impressive and then you could have uh
and then the synaptic firings we're
referring to is strictly the electrical
signals
that could be the mechanical
transmission information like this
chemical transmission of information
there's
there's all kinds of other stuff going
on and then there's memory that's built
in that's also all tied in
not to mention which i'm learning more
and more about
it's not just about the uh the neurons
it's also about the immune system
that's somehow helping with the
computation so it's the entirety
and the entire body is helping with the
computation so the three bananas
it could buy you a lot it could buy you
a lot
but on the topic of sort of uh
the greater degrees of complexity
emerging in consciousness i think
few things are as beautiful and
inspiring
as taking a step outside of the human
brain just looking at systems
where simple rules create
incredible complexity uh not create
incredible complexity emerges so
one of the simplest things to do that
with is the cellular automata
and there's i don't know what it is and
maybe you can speak to it
we can certainly we will certainly talk
about the implications of this but
there's so few things that are as
awe-inspiring to me
as knowing the rules of a system and not
being able to predict what the heck it
looks like and it creates incredibly
beautiful complexity that when zoomed
out on
looks like there's actual organisms
doing things
that are much uh that operate on scale
much higher than the underlying
mechanism so with cellular automata
that's cells that
are born and die born or die and they
only know about each other's neighbors
and there's simple rules that govern
that interaction of birth and death
and then they create at scale organisms
that
look like they take up hundreds or
thousands of cells
and they're moving they're moving around
they're communicating they're sending
signals to each other
and you forget at moments at a time
before you remember that the simple
rules
on cells is all that it took to create
that
that's it's sad
in that we can't come up with a simple
description of that system
that generalizes the behavior of the
large organisms
we can only come up we can only hope to
come up with the thing the fundamental
physics
or the fundamental rules of that system
i suppose it's sad that we can't predict
everything we know about the mathematics
of those systems it seems like we can't
really in a nice way like economics
tries to do to predict how this whole
thing will unroll
but it's beautiful because how simple it
is underneath it all
so what do you make of
the emergence of complexity from simple
rules
what the hell is that about yeah well we
can see that something like
flocking behavior the murmuration can
can be computer-coded it's not a very
hard set of rules to be able to see
some of those really amazing types of
complexity
and the whole field of complexity
science and some of the
sub disciplines like stigma g are are
studying how
following fairly simple responses to a
pheromone signal do ant colonies do this
amazing thing where the
what you might describe is the
organizational computational capacity of
the colony
is so profound relative to what each
individual
ants is doing i am not um
anywhere near as well versed in the
cutting edge of cellular automata as i
would like unfortunately i
in terms of topics that i would like to
get to and haven't like
et's more wolfram's a new kind of
science i have only
skimmed and read reviews of and not read
the whole thing or his newer work since
um but his idea of the four
basic kind of categories of uh emergent
phenomena that can come from cellular
automata and that one of them is kind of
interesting and looks a lot like
complexity rather than just chaos or
homogeneity or
self-termination or whatever
i think this is very interesting
it does not instantly make me think that
uh biology
is operating on a similarly small set of
rules and or the human consciousnesses
i'm
i'm not that reductionistly oriented and
um so if you look
at say santa fe institute one of the
co-founders stuart kaufman
um his work he should you should really
get him on your show so
a lot of the questions that you like one
of kaufman's you know more recent books
after investigations and some of the
real fundamental stuff was called
reinventing the sacred and it had to do
with some of these exact questions
uh in kind of non-reductionist approach
but that is not
just silly hippie-ism um and he was very
interested in highly non-ergotic systems
where
you couldn't take a lot of behavior over
a small period of time and predict what
the behavior of
subsets over a longer period of time
would do um
and then going further someone who spent
some time at santa fe institute and then
kind of
made a whole new field that you should
have on dave snowden
who some people call the father of
anthrocomplexity or what is the
complexity unique to humans
uh he says something to the effect of
that modeling humans as termites really
doesn't cut it like
we we don't respond exactly identically
to
the same pheromone stimulus using stigma
g like it works for flows of traffic and
some very simple human
behaviors but it really doesn't work for
trying to make sense of the sistine
chapel and picasso and general
relativity creation and stuff like that
and it's because the the termites are
not doing abstraction
forecasting deep into the future and
making choices now based on forecasts of
the future not just adaptive signals in
the moment an evolutionary code from
history
that's really different right like
making choices now that can factor deep
modeling of the future
and with humans our uniqueness
one to the next in terms of response to
similar stimuli
is much higher than it is with a termite
um
one of the interesting things there is
that their uniqueness is extremely low
they're basically fungible within a
class
right the different classes but within a
class they're basically fungible and
their system uses that very high numbers
and lots of um loss right like
that the termite feels that way don't
you think we humans are deceiving
ourselves about our uniqueness perhaps
it doesn't just isn't there some sense
in which this emerges just creates
different
higher and higher levels of abstraction
where every at every layer
each organism feels unique is that
possible
that we're all equally dumb but at
different scales no i think uniqueness
is evolving
i think that hydrogen atoms are more
similar to each other
than cells of the same type are and i
think that cells are more similar to
each other than humans are
i think that highly k k-selected species
are more unique than our selected
species so they're different
evolutionary processes
they are selected species where you have
a whole a lot of death
and very high birth rates you're not
looking for
as much individuality within
or individual possible expression to
cover the evolutionary search space
within an individual you're looking at
it more in terms of a numbers game
um so yeah i would say there's probably
more
difference between one orca and the next
than there is between one cape
buffalo and the next given that it will
be interesting to get your thoughts
about
mimetic theory where we're imitating
each other
in the context of this idea of
uniqueness
how much truth is there to that uh how
compelling is this
world view to you of gerardian
mimetic theory of desire where
maybe you can explain it from your
perspective but it seems like imitating
each other is the fundamental
property of the behavior of human
civilization
well imitation is not unique to humans
right monkeys imitate
um so a certain amount of learning
through observing
is not unique to humans humans do more
of it
uh it's actually kind of worth speaking
to this for a moment
um monkeys can learn new behaviors new
we've even seen teaching an ape sign
language and then the ape teaching other
apes sign language
um so that's a kind of mimesis right
kind of learning through imitation
and that needs to happen if they need to
learn or develop capacities that are not
just coded by their genetics right
so within the same genome they're
learning new things based on the
environment
and so based on someone else learn
something first and
so let's pick it up uh how
much a creature is the result of just
its genetic programming and how much
it's learning is a very interesting
question and i think this is a place
where humans really show up radically
different than everything else
and you can see it in the in the neonate
how long we're basically
fetal um that a
the closest ancestors to us if we look
at a chimp a chimp can
hold on to its mother's fur while she
moves around day one
and obviously we see horses up and
walking within 20 minutes
the fact that it takes a human a year to
be walking and it takes horse 20 minutes
and you say how many multiples of 20
minutes go into a year like that's a
long period of helplessness
that it wouldn't work for a horse right
like they or anything else
and and not only could we not hold on to
mom
in the first day it's three months
before we can move our head volitionally
um so it's like why why are we embryonic
for so
long basically that it's like
like it's still fetal on the outside had
to be because
couldn't keep growing inside and
actually ever get out with big heads and
narrower hips from going upright
um so here's a place where there's a
co-evolution of the pattern of humans
specifically here are our neotony and
what that pertends to learning
with our being tool-making and
environment modifying creatures
which is because we have the abstraction
to make tools
we change our environments more than
other creatures change their
environments
the next most environment modifying
creature to us is like a beaver
and then you we're in la you fly into
lax and you look at the just
orthogonal grid going on forever in all
directions
and you know we've recently come into
the anthropocene where the
surface of the earth is changing more
from human activity than geological
activity
and then beavers and you're like okay
wow we're really in a class of our own
in terms of environments
modifying yeah um so as
soon as we started tool making
we were able to change our environments
much more radically we could put on
clothes and go to a cold place right
and this is really important because we
actually went and became apex predators
in every environment
we functioned like apex predators the
polar bear can't leave the arctic
right and the lion can't leave the
savannah and
orca can't leave the ocean and we went
became apex predators in all those
environments because of our tool
creation capacity we could become better
predators than them adapted to the
environment or at least with our tools
adapted to the environment
so in every aspect towards any organism
in any environment we're incredibly good
at becoming apex predators
yes and nothing else can do that kind of
thing there
there is no other apex predator that you
see the other apex predator is only
getting better at being a predator
through evolutionary process that's
super slow
and that super slow process creates
co-selective process with their
environment so as the predator becomes a
tiny bit faster
it eats more of the slow prey the genes
of the fast prey and breed and the prey
becomes faster
and so there's this kind of balancing
and we in
because of our tool making we increased
our predatory capacity faster than
anything
else could increase its resilience to it
as a result we start outstripping
the environment and extincting species
following stone tools
and going and becoming apex predator
everywhere this is why we can't keep
applying apex predator series because
we're not an apex predator we're an apex
predator but we're something much more
than that
like just for an example the top apex
predator in the world in orca
and orca can eat one big fish at a time
like one tuna and it'll miss most of the
time
or one seal and we can put a mile-long
drift net out on a single boat
and pull up an entire school of them
right we can
deplete the entire oceans of them that's
not an orca right like that's not an
apex predator
um and that's not even including that we
can then genetically engineer
different creatures we can extinct
species we can devastate whole
ecosystems we can make built worlds that
have no natural things that are just
human built worlds we can build new
types of natural creatures synthetic
life
so we are much more like little gods
than we are like apex predators now but
we're still behaving as apex predators
and little gods that behave as apex
predators caused us a problem
kind of core to my assessment of the
world
so what does it mean to be a predator so
a predator is
somebody that effectively can mine the
resources from a place
so for their survival or is it also
just purely like higher level
objectives of violence and what is can
predators be predators towards the same
each other towards the same species
like we think are we using the word
predator sort of generally
which then connects to conflict and uh
military conflict violent conflict
in the space of human species obviously
we can say that plants are mining the
resources of their environment in a
particular way
using photosynthesis to be able to pull
minerals out of the soil and
nitrogen and carbon out of the air and
like that
um and we can say herbivores are being
able to mine and concentrate that so i
wouldn't say mining the environment is
unique to predator
predator is you know
uh
generally being defined as mining
other animals right we don't consider
herbivores
predators but um animal which requires
some type of violence capacity because
animals move plants don't move so
requires some capacity to
uh overtake something that can move and
try to get away
um we'll go back to the gerard zing and
we'll come back here
why are we neon this why are we
embryonic for so long
because are we did we just move from the
savannah to the arctic and we need to
learn new stuff
if we came genetically programmed we
would not be able to do that
are we throwing spears or are we fishing
or are we
running an industrial supply chain or
are we texting what is the adaptive
behavior
horses today in the wild and horses ten
thousand years ago are doing pretty much
the same stuff
and so since we make tools and we evolve
our tools
and then change our environments so
quickly and other animals are largely
the result of their environment but
we're
environment modifying so rapidly we need
to come without too much programming so
we can learn the environment we're in
learn the language right which is uh
going to be very important learn the
tool making learn the um
and so we have a very long period of
relative helpless
of helplessness because we aren't coded
how to behave yet because we're
imprinting a lot of software on how to
behave that is useful to
that particular time so our mimesis is
not it's not unique to humans but the
total amount of it is really unique
and this is also where the uniqueness
can go up right is because we are less
just the result of the genetics and that
means the kind of
learning through history that they got
coded in genetics and more the result of
it's almost like our hardware selected
for software
right like if evolution is kind of doing
these think of as a hardware selection
i have problems with computer metaphors
for biology but i'll use this one here
um that we
have not had hardware changes since the
beginning of sapiens but our world is
really really different
and that's all changes in software right
changes in
on the same fundamental genetic
substrate
what we're doing with these brains and
minds and bodies and social groups and
like that and so um
now gerard specifically was looking at
when
we watch other people talking so we
learn language you and i would have a
hard time learning mandarin today it
would take a lot of work we'd be
learning how to conjugate verbs and
stuff but a baby learns it instantly
without anyone even really trying to
teach it just through mimesis so it's a
it's a powerful thing
they're obviously more neuroplastic than
we are when they're doing that and all
their attention is allocated that
but they're also learning how to move
their bodies and they're learning
all kinds of stuff through mimesis one
of the things that george says is
they're also learning what to want
and they learn what to want they learn
desire by watching what other people
want
and so intrinsic to this people end up
wanting what other people want
and if we can't have what other people
have without taking it away from them
then that becomes a source of conflict
so the mimesis of desire is the
fundamental generator of conflict
and that then the conflict energy within
a group of people will build over time
this is a very very crude interpretation
of the theory
can we just pause on that for people who
are not familiar
and for me who hasn't i'm loosely
familiar but i haven't internalized it
but every time i think about it's a very
compelling view of the world whether
it's true or not
it's quite it's like when you take
everything freud says as truth is a very
interesting way to think about the world
in the same way thinking about the
memetic
theory of desire that everything we want
is imitation of other people's wants we
don't have any original wants
we're constantly imitating others and so
and not just others but you know others
were exposed to
so there's these like little local
pockets however defined local
of people like imitating each other and
uh
one that's super empowering because then
you can pick which group you can join
like what what do you want to imitate
it's
it's uh it's the old like uh you know
whoever your friends are
that's what your life is gonna be like
that's really powerful i mean it's
depressing that we're so
unoriginal but it's also liberating in
that
if this holds true that we can choose
our life by choosing the people we hang
out with
so okay thoughts that are very
compelling that seem like they're more
absolute than they
actually are end up also being dangerous
we want communism um
i'm gonna discuss here where i think we
need to amend this particular
theory but specifically you just said
something that everyone
who's paid attention knows is true
experientially which is who you're
around affects who you become
and as as libertarian and
self-determining and sovereign as we'd
like to be
um everybody i think knows that if you
got put in a maximum security prison
aspects of your personality would have
to adapt or you wouldn't
survive there right you would become
different if you were
if if you grew up in darfur versus
finland you would be different with your
same genetics like
just there's no real question about that
um
and that even today if you hang out in a
place
with ultra marathoners as your roommates
or
um all people who are obese as your
roommates the statistical likelihood of
what happens to your fitness is pretty
clear
right like the behavioral science of
this is pretty clear so uh
the whole saying we are the average of
the five people we spend the most time
around
i think the more self-reflective someone
is the more time they spend by
themselves in self-reflection the less
this is true but it's still true
so one of the best things someone can do
to become more self-determined is be
self-determined about the environments
they want to put themselves in
because to the degree that there is some
self-determination and some
determination by the environment
don't be fighting an environment that is
predisposing you in bad directions
try to put yourself in an environment
that is predisposing the things that you
want
in turn try to affect the environment in
ways that predispose positive things for
those around you
or perhaps also to there there's
probably interesting ways to play with
this you could probably
put yourself like form connections that
have this perfect tension in all
directions to where you're actually free
to decide whatever the heck you want
because
the set of wants within your circle of
interactions
is so conflicting that you're free to
choose whichever one
so if there's enough tension as opposed
to everybody align like a flock of birds
yeah you i mean you definitely want that
all of the dialectics
would be balanced um so if you have
someone who is extremely oriented to
self-empowerment and someone who's
extremely oriented to kind of empathy
and compassion both
the dialectic of those is better than
either of them on their own
um if you have both of them inhabiting
being inhabited better than you by the
same person spending time around that
person will probably do
well for you i think the thing you just
mentioned is super important when it
comes to cognitive
schools which is
i think one of the fastest things people
can do to improve their learning
and their not just cognitive learning
but their
meaningful problem-solving communication
and civic capacity capacity to
participate as a citizen with other
people and making the world better
is to be seeking dialectical synthesis
all the time
and so in the hegelian sense if you have
a thesis
you have an antithesis so maybe we have
libertarianism on one side and marxist
kind of communism on the other side and
one is arguing that
the individual is the unit of choice
and so we want to uh increase the
freedom and support of individual choice
because as they
make more agentic choices it'll produce
a better hole for everybody
the other side saying well the
individuals are conditioned by their
environment who would choose to be born
into darfur rather than finland
um so we actually need to collectively
make environments
that are good because that the
environment conditions individuals
so you have a thesis and an antithesis
and then
hegel's ideas you have a synthesis which
is a kind of higher order truth that
understands how those relate in a way
that neither of them do and so it is
actually at a higher order of complexity
so the first part would be can i steal
man each of these can i argue each one
well enough that the proponents of it
are like totally you got that
and not just argue it rhetorically but
can i inhabit it where i can
try to see and feel the world the way
someone seeing and feeling the world
that way would
because once i do then i don't want to
screw those people because there's truth
in it
right and i'm not going to go back to
war with them i'm going to go to finding
solutions it could actually work at a
higher order
if i don't go to a higher order then
there's war
and but then the higher order thing
would be well it seems like the
individual
does affect the commons and the
collective and other people it also
seems like
the collective conditions individuals at
least statistically
and i can cherry pick out the one guy
who got out of the ghetto
um and pulled himself up by his
bootstraps but i can also say
statistically that most people born into
the ghetto show up differently than most
people born into the hamptons
and so unless you want to argue that and
have you
take your child from the hamptons and
put them in the ghetto then like come on
be realistic about this thing
so how do we make we don't want social
systems that make
weak dependent individuals right so the
welfare argument but we also
don't want no social system that
supports individuals to do better
we want we don't want individuals where
their
self-expression and agency [ __ ] the
environment and everybody else and
employs slave labor and whatever
so can we make it to where individuals
are creating holes that are better for
conditioning other individuals can we
make it to where we have holes that are
conditioning increased
agency and sovereignty right that would
be the synthesis so the thing
that i'm coming to here is if people
have that as a frame and sometimes it's
not just thesis and antithesis it's like
eight different views
right can i steal man each view
this is not just can i take the
perspective but am i seeking them am i
actively trying to inhabit other
people's perspective
then can i really try to essentialize it
and argue
the best points of it both the sense
making about reality and the values
why these values actually matter then
just like i want to seek those
perspectives then i want to seek
is there a higher order set of
understandings that could fulfill the
values of
and synthesize the sense making of all
of them simultaneously
maybe i won't get it but i want to be
seeking it and i want to be seeking
progressively better ones
so this is perspective seeking driving
perspective taking
and then seeking synthesis
i think that that one
cognitive disposition might be
the most helpful thing would you put a
title dialectic synthesis
on that process because that seems to be
such a part so like this
rigorous empathy like
like it's not just empathy it's empathy
with the rigor like you
really want to understand and and embody
different world views and then try to
find a higher order synthesis
okay so i remember last night you told
me when we first met
uh you said that you looked in
somebody's eyes and you felt that you
had
suffered in some ways that they had
suffered and so you could trust them
shared pathos right creates a certain
sense of kind of shared
bonding and shared intimacy so empathy
is actually feeling the suffering of
somebody else and feeling the
the depth of their sentience i don't
want to [ __ ] them anymore
i may not hurt them i don't want to
behave and i don't want my proposition
to go through
when i go and inhabit the perspective of
the other people if they feel that's
really going to mess them up
right and so the rigorous empathy it's
different than just compassion which is
i generally care
like i have a generalized care but i
don't know what it's like to be them
i can never know what it's like to be
them perfectly and that there's a
humility you have to have which is
my most rigorous attempt is still not it
my most rigorous attempt mine to know
what it's like to be a woman is still
not it i have no question that if i was
actually a woman it would be different
than my best guesses
i have no question if i was actually
black it's be different than my best
guesses
so there's a humility in that which
keeps me listening because i don't think
that i know fully
but i want to and i'm going to keep
trying better to
and then i want to across them and then
i want to say is there a way we can
forward together and not have to be in
war
it has to be something that could meet
the values that everyone holds
it could reconcile the partial sense
making that everyone holds
and they could offer a way forward that
is more agreeable
than the partial perspectives at war
with each other but the so the more
you succeed at this empathy with
humility
the more you're carrying the burden of
their of other people's pain
essentially it just goes back to the
question of do i see us as one
being or 7.8 billion
i think the
if i'm overwhelmed with my own pain i
can't empathize that much
because i don't have the bandwidth i
don't have the capacity if i don't feel
like i can do something about a
particular problem in the world it's
hard to feel it because it's just too
devastating
and so a lot of people go numb and even
go nihilistic
because they just don't feel the agency
so as i actually become more empowered
as an individual
and have more sense of agency i also
become more empowered to be more
empathetic for others and be more
connected
to that shared burden and want to be
able to make choices
on behalf of and in in benefit of so
this way of living
seems like a way of living that would
solve a lot of problems in society
from a cellular automata perspective so
if you have a bunch of little
like little agents behaving in this way
my intuition there'll be interesting
complexities that emerge but my
intuition is
it will create a society that's very
different and recognizably
better than the one we have today
how much um like oh wait hold that
question because i want to come back to
it but this brings us back to gerard
which we didn't answer
the conflict theory yes because about
how to get past the conflict theory yes
you know the robert frost poem about the
two paths he never has
time to return back to the other we're
gonna have to do that quite a lot we're
gonna be
uh living that poem over and over again
but yes
how how to uh let's return back
okay so the rest of the argument goes
you learn to want what other people
want therefore fundamental conflict
based in our desire because we want the
thing that somebody else has
and then people are conf they're in
conflict over trying to get the same
stuff
power status attention physical stuff a
mate whatever it is
and then we learn the conflict by
watching and so then the conflict
becomes medic so the
and you know we become on the
palestinian side
of the israeli side of the communist
capitalist side or the left to right
politically or whatever it is
and until eventually the conflict energy
in the system builds up so much
that some type of violence is needed to
get the bad guy whoever it is that we're
gonna blame
and you know george talks about why
scapegoating was kind of a mechanism to
minimize the amount of violence let's
blame let's blame it a
sec a scapegoat as being more relevant
than they really were but if we all
believe it then we can all kind of calm
down with the conflict energy
it's a really interesting concept by the
way i mean you went you
beautifully summarized it but the idea
that there's a scapegoat that there's a
this kind of thing naturally leads to a
conflict and then they find the other
some group that's the other that's
either real artificial as the cause of
the conflict
well it's always artificial because the
cause of the conflict in gerard is the
mimesis of desire itself and how do we
attack that
how do we attack that it's our own
desire so this now gets to something
more like buddha said
right which was desire as the cause of
suffering um
gerard and buddha would kind of agree in
this way
so and so but that's that explains i
mean again it's a compelling
description of human history that we do
tend to
come up with the other and uh okay kind
of
i just i just had such a funny
experience with someone critiquing
gerard the other day in such a
um elegant and beautiful and simple way
it's a
a friend who's uh
grew up aboriginal australian uh as a
scholar of
aboriginal social technologies
he's like nah man gerard just made [ __ ]
up about how tribes work like we
come from a tribe we've got tens of
thousands of years and we didn't have
increasing conflict and then scapegoat
and kill someone
we'd have a little bit of conflict and
then we would dance and then everybody'd
be fine
like we'd dance around the campfire
everyone would like kind of physically
get the energy out we'd look in each
other's eyes we'd have positive bonding
and then we're fine and nobody no
scapegoats and
i think that's called the joe rogan
theory of desire which is
uh he's like all all of human problems
have to do with the fact that you don't
do enough hard [ __ ] in your day
yeah so maybe maybe you could just dance
it because he says like
doing exercising running on the
treadmill gets gets all the demons out
maybe just dancing gets all the demons
out
so this is why i say we have to be
careful with taking an idea
that seems too explanatory and then
taking it as a given and then saying
well now that we're stuck with the fact
that
conflict is inexorable because human
because memetic desire and therefore how
do we deal with the inexorability of the
conflict and how to sublimate violence
well
no the whole thing might be actually
gibberish meaning it's only true in
certain conditions and other conditions
it's not true so the deeper question is
under which conditions is that true
under which conditions is it not true
what do those other conditions make
possible and look like
and in general we should stay with
really compelling models
of reality because there's something
about about our brains that these models
become sticky and we can't even think
outside of them
so it's not that we stay away from them
it's that we know that the model of
reality is never reality
that's the key thing humility again it
goes back to just having the humility
they don't have a perfect model of
reality
there's an ep the model of reality could
never be reality the process of modeling
is inherently
information reduction and
i can never show that the unknown
unknown set has been factored
um it's back to the cellular automata
you can't
you can't uh put the genie back in the
bottle
like when you realize it's unfortunately
sadly impossible to um
to create a model of cellular automata
even if you know the basic rules
that predict to even any degree of
accuracy
what uh um how that
system will evolve which is fascinating
mathematically sorry i i think about it
quite a lot
it's very annoying wolfram has this rule
30
like you should be able to predict it
it's so
simple but you can't predict what's
going to be
like there's a there's a problem he
defines they try to predict some aspect
of the middle
middle column of the system just
anything about it
what's going to happen in the future and
you can't you can't
it sucks because then we can't make
sense of this world
you know really in of reality in a
definitive way
it's always like in the striving like it
we're always striving yeah i don't think
this sucks
that so that's a feature not a bug
well that's assuming a designer um
i would say i don't think it sucks i
think it's
not only beautiful but maybe necessary
for beauty
the mess so you're uh so you're you
disagree jordan peterson you should
clean up your room
see you like the room's messy it's uh
it's essential for the
for beauty it's not it's not
okay i take i have no idea if it was
intended this way
and so i'm just interpreting it a way i
like the
commandment about having no false idols
to me the way i interpret that that is
meaningful
is that re reality is sacred to me i
have a reverence for reality
but i know my best understanding of it
is never complete
i know my best model of it is a model
where i
tried to make some kind of predictive
capacity by reducing the complexity of
it to
a set of stuff that i could observe and
then a subset of that stuff that i
thought was the causal dynamics and then
some set of
you know mechanisms that are involved
and what we find is that
it can be super useful like newtonian
gravity can help us
do ballistic curves and all kinds of
super useful stuff and then we get to
the place where it doesn't
explain what's happening at the
cosmological scale or at a
quantum scale and at each time what
we're finding is
uh we excluded stuff and it also doesn't
explain the reconciliation
of gravity with quantum mechanics and
the other kind of fundamental laws and
the
so models can be useful but they're
never true with a capital t
meaning they're never an actual real
full they're never a complete
description of what's happening in real
systems they can be a complete
description of what's happening in an
artificial system that was the result of
applying a model
so the model of a circuit board and the
circuit board are the same thing but i
would argue that the model of a cell in
the cell are not the same thing
and i would say this is key to what we
call complexity
versus the complicated which is a
distinction dave snowden made
well in defining the difference between
simple complicated complex and chaotic
systems
um but one of the definers in complex
systems is that no matter how you model
the complex system it will still have
some emergent behavior not predicted by
the model
can you elaborate on the complex versus
the complicated complicated means we can
fully explicate
the face space of all the things that it
can do we can program it
uh all human not all
for the most part human-built things are
complicated they don't self-organize
they don't self-repair they're not
self-evolving and we can
make a blueprint for them we're sorry
for human systems
for human technologies human
technologies sorry
okay so that are basically the
application of models
right right and engineering is kind of
applied science science as the modeling
process and but
with but humans are complex complex
stuff with biological type stuff
and sociological type stuff it more has
generator functions
and even those can't be fully explicated
then it has
or our explication can't prove that it
has closure of what would be in the
unknown unknown set where we keep
finding like oh it's just the genome oh
well now it's the genome in the
epigenome and then a recursive change on
the epigenome because of the proteome
and then there's mitochondrial dna and
then
virus is affected and [ __ ] right so it's
like we get overexcited
when we think we found the thing so on
facebook you know how you can list your
relationship as complicated it should
actually say
it's it's complex that's the more
accurate description
you uh self-terminating is a really
interesting idea that you talk about
quite a bit
first of all what is a self-terminating
system and
i think you have a sense correct me if
i'm wrong that
human civilization as it currently is is
a self-terminating system
why do you have that intuition combined
with the definition of what
self-terminating means
okay so if we look at
human societies historically human
civilizations
uh it's not that hard to realize that
most of the major
civilizations and empires of the past
don't exist anymore so they had a life
cycle they died for some reason
so we don't still have in the early
egyptian empire or inca or maya or aztec
or
any of those right and so they
they terminated sometimes it seems like
they were terminated from the outside in
war sometimes it seems like they
self-terminate when we look at easter
island it was a self-termination
um so uh let's go ahead and take an
island situation if i have an island
and we're consuming the resources on
that island faster than the resources
can replicate themselves and there's a
finite space there
that system is going to self-terminate
it's not going to be able to keep doing
that thing
because you'll get to a place of there's
no resources left
and then you get uh so now
if i'm utilizing the resources faster
than they can replicate
or fasten they can replenish and i'm
actually growing our population in the
process i'm even
increasing the rate of the utilization
of resources
i might get an exponential curve and
then hit a wall and then just collapse
the exponential curve rather than do an
s curve or some other kind of thing
so self-terminating system is any system
that depends upon a substrate system
that is debasing its own substrate it is
debasing what it depends upon
so you're right that uh if you look at
empires
they rise and fall throughout human
history but
but not this time bro where
this one's gonna last forever that's i
like that idea
i think that if we don't understand why
all the previous ones failed we can't
ensure that and so i think it's very
important to understand it well so that
we can
have that be a designed outcome with
somewhat
decent probability so we're it's sort of
in terms of consuming the resources on
the island
we're a clever bunch and we keep coming
up
especially when the on the horizon
there is a termination point we keep
coming up with clever ways of avoiding
disaster
of avoiding collapse of constructing
this is where technological innovation
this is where growth comes in
coming up with different ways to improve
productivity and the way society
functions
such that we consume less resources or
get a lot more from the resources we
have
so there's some sense in which there's a
human ingenuity is a source for optimism
about the future of this particular
system that
that may not be self-terminating if if
there's more innovation than there is
consumption so
over consumption of resources just one
way i think can self-terminate we're
just
kind of starting here but um
there are reasons for optimism and
pessimism then they're both worth
understanding and there's failure modes
on understanding either without the
other
as as we mentioned previously there
there's what i would call naive techno
optimism naive techno capital optimism
that says stuff just has been getting
better and better and we wouldn't want
to live in the dark ages and tech has
done all this awesome stuff and
um we know the proponents of those
models
uh and this stuff is going to kind of
keep getting better of course there are
problems but human ingenuity rises to it
supply and demand will solve the
problems whatever
would you put a red car as well on that
or uh
in that bucket is there some specific
people you have in mind or naive
optimism is
truly naive to where you're essentially
just have an optimism that's blind to
any kind of realities of the way
technology progresses
i don't think that anyone is
who thinks about it and writes about it
is perfectly naive
gotcha but there might be it's a
platonic ideal
there might be a bias in the nature of
the assessment
i would also say there's kind of naive
techno pessimism
and there are
critics of technology i mean you read
the unabomber's manifesto on why
technology can't not
result in our self-termination so we
have to take it out before it gets any
further
um but also if you read a lot of the
x-risk community you know bostrom and
friends uh it's like our total number of
existential risks
and the total probability of them is
going up
and so i think that there are
we have to hold together where our
positive possibilities and our risk
possibilities are both
increasing and then say for the positive
possibilities to be realized long term
all of the catastrophic risks have to
not happen
any of the catastrophic risks happening
is enough to keep
that positive outcome from occurring so
how do we ensure that none of them
happen
if we want to say let's have a
civilization that doesn't collapse
so again collapse theory it's worth
looking at books like
the collapse of complex societies by
joseph tainter it does an
analysis of that
many of the societies fell for for
internal
institutional decay civilizational decay
reasons
beaudriard in simulation and simulacra
looks at a very different way of looking
at how institutional decay and the
collective intelligence of a system
happens and it becomes kind of more
internally parasitic on itself
obviously jared diamond made a more
popular book called collapse
um and as we were mentioning the
anti-catheria mechanism
has been getting attention in the news
lately but it's like a 2 000 year old
clock right like
like metal gears and
does that mean we lost like 1500 years
of technological progress
um and from a society that was
relatively technologically advanced
um so
what i'm interested in here is being
able to say okay well
why did previous societies fail
can we understand that abstractly enough
that we can
make a civilizational model that isn't
just trying to solve one
type of failure but solve the underlying
things that generate the failures as a
whole
are there some underlying generator
functions or patterns
that would make a system
self-terminating and can we solve those
and have that be the kernel of a new
civilizational model that is not
self-terminating
and can we even be able to actually look
at the categories of x-rays we're aware
of and see that we actually have
resilience
in the presence of those not just
resilience but anti-fragility
and i would say for the optimism to be
grounded
it has to actually be able to understand
the risk space well
and have adequate solutions for it so
can we try to
dig into some basic intuitions about the
underlying
sources of catastrophic failures of the
system
and over consumption that's built into
self-terminating systems
so both the over consumption which is
like the slow death
and then there's the fast death of
nuclear war and all those kinds of
things
agi biotech bioengineering
nanotechnology now
my favorite nanobots okay
nanobots are my favorite because it
sounds so cool to me that i could just
know that i would be one of the
scientists that would be full steam
ahead
in building them without
sufficiently thinking about the negative
consequences i would definitely be
i would be podcasting all about the
negative consequences but
but when i go back home i'd be i just in
my heart
know the amount of excitement is a dumb
descendant of vape no offense to apes
uh so i want to backtrack on my previous
uh comments
about uh negative comments about apes
uh that i have that sense of excitement
that uh would result in problems so
sorry a lot of things said but
what can we start to pull a thread
because you've also provided kind of a
beautiful
general approach to this which is this
dialectic synthesis or just
rigorous empathy whatever whatever word
we want to put to it
that seems to be from the individual
perspective is one way to sort of
live in the world as we try to figure
out how to construct
non-self-terminating systems so what
what are some underlying sources
yeah first i have to say um
i i actually really respect
drexler for emphasizing grey goo and
engines of creation back in the day
um to make sure the world was paying
adequate attention to the risks of the
the nanotech um as someone who was right
at the
cutting edge of what could be um
there's definitely game theoretic
advantage to those who focus on the
opportunities and
don't focus on the risks or pretend
there aren't risks um
because they get to market first
um and then they externalize all of the
costs through
limited liability or whatever it is to
the commons or whatever happened to have
it other people are going to have to
solve those but now they have the power
and capital associated the person who
looked at the risks and tried to do
better design and go slower
um is probably not going to move into
positions of as much power influences
quickly so this one of the issues we
have to deal with is some of the
the bad game theoretic dispositions in
the system relative to its own
um stability and the key aspect to that
sorry to interrupt is the externalities
generated
yes what flavors of catastrophic risk
are we talking about here what's your
favorite flavor in terms of ice cream
so mine is coconut nobody seems to like
coconut ice cream so
ice cream aside what's
uh what are you most worried about if
there's a catastrophic risk that will
help us kind of um
make concrete the the the discussion
we're having about how to fix this whole
thing
yeah i think it's worth taking a
historical perspective
briefly to just kind of orient everyone
to it we don't have to
um go all the way back to the aliens
who've seen all of civilization but
to just recognize that
for all of human history as far as we're
aware
there were existential risks to
civilizations
and they happened right like there were
civilizations that were
killed in war that tribes that were
killed in tribal warfare or whatever so
uh people faced existential risks to the
group that they identified with
it's just those were local phenomena
right they it wasn't a fully global
phenomena so an empire could fall
and surrounding empires didn't fall
maybe they came in and filled the space
the first time that we were able to
think about catastrophic risk not from
like a solar flare or something that we
couldn't control but from
something that humans would actually
create at a global level was world war
ii in the bomb
because it was the first time that we
had tech big enough that could actually
mess up everything at a global level it
could mess up habitability we just
weren't powerful enough to do that
before
it's not that we didn't behave in ways
that would have done it we just
only behaved in those ways at the scale
we could affect and
so it's important to get that there's
the entire world before world war ii
where we don't have the ability to make
a non-habitable biosphere
non-inhabitable for us and then there's
world war ii and
the beginning of a completely new phase
where global
human induced catastrophic risk is now a
real thing
and that was such a big deal that it
changed the entire world in a really
fundamental way
which is you know when you study history
it's amazing how big a percentage of
history is studying war right in the the
history of wars you said european
history whatever
it's generals and wars and empire
expansions and and so the
the major empires near each other never
had really long periods of time where
they weren't engaged in war or
preparation for
or something like that that was humans
don't have a good
precedent in the post tribal phase the
civilization phase of being able to
solve conflicts without war for very
long
world war ii was the first time where
we could have a war that no one could
win
and so the superpowers couldn't fight
again they couldn't do a real kinetic
war
they could do diplomatic wars and cold
war type stuff and they could fight
proxy wars through other countries that
didn't have the big weapons
and so mutually assured destruction and
like coming out of world war
ii we actually realized that nation
states couldn't prevent
world war and so we needed a new type of
supervening government in addition to
nation states which was the whole
bretton woods world the
united nations the world bank the imf
the globalization trade type agreements
mutually assured destruction
that was how do we have some
coordination beyond
just nation states between them since we
have to stop war between at least the
superpowers
and it was pretty successful given that
we've had like 75 years of no
superpower on superpower war um
we've had lots of proxy wars during that
time we've had you know cold war
and i would say we're in a new phase now
where the bretton woods solution
is basically over almost over can you
describe the
breathless solution yeah so the bretton
woods
the series of agreements for
how uh the nations would be able to
engage with each other in a solution
other than war um was these igos these
intergovernmental organizations and was
the idea of
globalization since we could have global
effects we needed to be able to think
about things globally
where we had trade relationships with
each other where it would not be
profitable
to war with each other to be more
profitable to actually be able to trade
with each other so our own self-interest
was
you know going to drive our non-more
interest
um and so this started to look like
and obviously this this couldn't have
happened that much earlier either
because industrialization hadn't gotten
far enough to be able to do massive
global industrial supply chains and
ships
stuff around you know quickly but like
we were mentioning earlier
almost all the electronics that we use
today just basic cheap stuff for us is
made on six
continents made in many countries
there's no single country in the world
that could actually make many of the
things that we have and from the
raw material extraction to the plastics
and polymers and the
you know etc and so the i the idea that
we made a world that could do that kind
of
trade and create massive gdp growth we
could all work together to be able to
mine natural resources and grow stuff
with the rapid gdp growth there was the
idea that everybody could keep having
more
without having to take each other's
stuff and so that
that was part of kind of the bretton
woods post world war ii model
the other was that we would be so
economically interdependent that blowing
each other up would never make sense
that worked for a while now
it also brought us up into planetary
boundaries faster
the unrenewable use of resource and
turning those resources into
pollution on the other side of the
supply chain
so obviously that faster gdp growth
meant uh
the overfishing of the oceans and the
cutting down of the trees and the
climate change and the uh
mining toxic mining tailings going into
the water and the
mountaintop removal mining and all those
types of things that's the over
consumption side
of the of the risk that we're talking
about and so the answer of
let's do positive gdp is the answer
rapidly and exponentially obviously
accelerated
the planetary boundary side and that
started to be that that was thought
about for a long time but it started to
be modeled
with the club of rome and limits of
growth
and it but it's just very obvious to say
if you have a linear materials economy
where you take stuff
out of the earth faster whether it's
fish or trees or or ore
you take or oil you take it out of the
earth faster than it can replenish
itself
and you turn it into trash after using
it for a short period of time you put
the trash in the environment faster than
it can
process itself and there's toxicity
associated with both sides of this
you can't run an exponentially growing
linear materials economy on a finite
planet forever that's not a hard thing
to figure out
and it has to be exponential if there's
an exponentiation in the monetary supply
because of interest and then fractional
reserve banking and to then be able to
keep up with the growing monetary supply
you have to have growth of goods and
services and
so that's that kind of thing that has
happened um
but you also see that when you get these
supply chains that are so interconnected
across the world
you get increased fragility because a
collapse or a problem in one area then
affects the whole world in a much bigger
area as opposed to the issues being
local
right so we got to see with covid and
an issue that started in one part of
china affecting the whole world
so much more rapidly than would have
happened
before bretton woods right before
international travel supply chains
you know that whole kind of thing and
with a bunch of second and third-order
effects that people wouldn't have
predicted okay we have to stop
certain kinds of travel because of viral
contaminants but
the countries doing agriculture depend
upon fertilizer they don't produce that
is shipped into them and depend upon
pesticides they don't produce so we got
both
crop failures and crops being eaten by
locusts in scale in northern africa and
iran and things like that because they
couldn't get the supplies of stuff in so
then you get massive starvation
or future kind of hunger issues because
of supply chain shutdowns
so you get this increased fragility and
cascade dynamics where a small problem
can end up leading to cascade effects
and also we went from
two superpowers with one catastrophe
weapon
to now that same catastrophe
weapon is there's more countries
that have it eight or nine countries
that have it and
there's a lot more types of catastrophe
weapons
we now have catastrophe weapons with
weaponized drones that can hit
infrastructure targets with bio with
in fact every new type of tech has
created an arms race
so we have not with the un or the other
kind of intergovernmental organizations
we haven't been able to really do
nuclear de-proliferation
we've actually had more countries get
nukes and keep getting faster nukes the
race to
hypersonics and things like that and
every new type of technology that has
emerged has created an arms race
and so you can't do mutually assured
destruction
with multiple agents the way you can
with two agents two agents it's a
much easier to create a stable nash
equilibrium that's forced
but the ability to monitor and say if
these guys shoot who do i shoot do i
shoot them do i shoot everybody do i
and so you get a three body problem you
get a very complex type of thing when
you have multiple agents and
multiple different types of catastrophe
weapons including ones that can be much
more easily produced than
nukes are really hard to produce there's
only uranium in a few areas uranium
enrichment is hard icbms are hard
but weaponized drones hitting smart
targets is not so hard there's a lot of
other things where basically the scale
at being able to manufacture them is
going way way down to where even
non-state actors can have them
and so when we talk about exponential
tech
and the decentralization of exponential
tech what that means is decentralized
catastrophe weapon
capacity and especially in a world of
increasing numbers of people feeling
disenfranchised frantic whatever for
different reasons
so uh i would say
where the bretton woods world doesn't
prepare us to be able to deal with lots
of different agents
having lots of different types of
catastrophe weapons you can't put
mutually assured destruction on
where you can't keep doing growth of
materials economy
in the same way because of hitting
planetary boundaries
and where the fragility dynamics are
actually now their own source of
catastrophic risk so now we're
so like there was all the world until
world war ii and world war ii is just
from a
from a civilization time scale point of
view was just a second ago
it seems like a long time but it is
really not we get a short period of
relative peace at the level of
superpowers while building up the
military capacity for much much much
worse war the entire time
and then now we're at this new phase
where the things that
allowed us to make it through the
nuclear power are not the same systems
that will let us make it through the
next
stage so what is this next post bretton
woods
how how do we become safe vessels
safe stewards of many different types of
exponential technology
is a key question when we're thinking
about x-risk
okay so and i i'd like to
try to answer the how if you thought a
few ways but first
on the mutually assured destruction
do you give credit to the idea
of two superpowers not blowing each
other up with nuclear weapons
to the simple game theoretic model of
mutually shared destruction
or something you've said previously
this idea of inverse correlation which i
tend to believe between
the now if you were talking about tech
but i think it's
maybe broadly true the inverse
correlation between competence and
propensity for destruction
so the better
the the the bigger your weapons not
because you're afraid of uh
mutually assured self-destruction but
because we're human beings and there's
a deep moral fortitude there
that's somehow aligned with competence
and being good at your job
that like it's very hard to be
a psychopath and be good
at killing at scale
do you share any of that intuition kind
of
i think most people would say that
alexander the great and genghis khan and
napoleon were effective
people that were good at their job
that were actually maybe asymmetrically
good
at being able to organize people and do
certain kinds of things
that were pretty oriented towards
certain types of destruction
um or pretty willing to maybe they would
say they were oriented towards empire
expansion but pretty willing to
commit certain acts of destruction in
the name of it what what are you worried
about
the genghis khan or
you could argue he's not a psychopath uh
that are you worried about genghis khan
are you worried about hitler or are you
worried about
a terrorist who is
has a very different ethic which is not
even
for uh from it's not trying to preserve
and build and expand my community
it's more about just destruction in
itself is the goal
i think the thing that you're looking at
that i do agree with
is that there's a psychological
disposition towards construction
right and the psychological disposition
more towards destruction obviously
everybody has both and can toggle
between both
and oftentimes one is willing to destroy
certain things we have this idea of
creative destruction right willing to
destroy certain things to create other
things
and utilitarianism and trolley problems
are all about exploring that space and
the idea of
war is all about that i am trying to
create something for our people
and it requires destroying some other
people um
sociopathy is a funny topic because it's
possible to have very high fealty to
your in-group
and work on perfecting the methods of
torture to the out group
um at the same time because you can
dehumanize and then remove empathy
um and
i would also say that there are types
so the reason the thing that gives hope
about the orientation towards
construction and destruction
being a little different in psychologies
is what it takes to build really
catastrophic tech
even today where it doesn't take what it
took to make a new small group people
could do it
takes still some real technical
knowledge
that required having studied for a while
and some been building capacity
and there's a question of is that
psychologically
inversely correlated with the desire to
damage civilization meaningfully
a little bit a little bit i think um
i think a lot i think it's actually i
mean
this is the conversation i had like with
i think offline with dan carlin
which is like it's pretty easy to come
up with ways
that any competent i can come up with a
lot of ways to hurt a lot of people
and it's pretty easy like i alone can do
it
and like
there's a lot of people as smart or
smarter than me
at least in the creation of explosives
why
are we not seeing more insane
mass murder i i think there's something
fascinating and beautiful about this yes
and it does have to do with some deeply
pro-social types of characteristics in
humans and
um but when you're dealing with very
large numbers
you don't need a whole lot of a
phenomena and so then you start to say
well what's the probability that x won't
happen this year then won't happen in
the next two years three years four
years
and then how many people are doing
destructive things with lower tech
and then how many of them can get access
to higher tech that they didn't have to
figure out how to build
so when i can get
commercial tech and maybe i don't
understand tech very well but
i understand it well enough to utilize
it not to create it and i can repurpose
it
when we saw that commercial drone with a
homemade thermite bomb hit the ukraine
ukrainian munitions factory and do the
equivalent of an incendiary bomb
level of damage that's just home tech
that's just simple
kind of thing and so the
question is not what is does it stay
being a small percentage of the
population the question is
does can you bind that phenomena nearly
completely
and especially now when you as you start
to get into
bigger things crisper gene drive
technologies and various things like
that
can you bind it completely long term
over what period of time not perfectly
though that's the thing i'm trying
i'm trying to say that there is some
let's call it uh let's uh a random word
love that's inherent in
that's core to human nature that's
preventing
destruction at scale and you're saying
yeah but there's a lot of humans there's
going to be eight plus billion
and then there's a lot of seconds in the
day to come up with stuff there's a lot
of pain in the world that can lead to a
distorted view of the world such that
you want to channel that pain into the
destruction
all those kinds of things and it's only
a matter of time that any one individual
can do large damage
especially as we create more and more
democratized decentralized ways to
deliver that damage even if you don't
know how to build the
initial weapon you can but the thing is
it seems like it's a race between
the cheapening of destructive weapons
and the capacity of humans to express
their love
towards each other and it's a race that
so far
i know on twitter you it's not popular
to say but
love is winning okay so what is the
argument that love is going to lose here
against uh nuclear weapons and biotech
and
and ai and uh and drones
okay i'm gonna come at the end of this
to a how love wins so i just want you to
know that that's where i'm oriented
that's the end but i'm i'm going to
argue against
why that is a given because it
because it's not a given i don't believe
and i think
this is a good romantic comedy so you're
going to create drama right now
but it will end in a happy ending well
it's because it's only a happy ending if
we actually understand the issues well
enough and take responsibility to shift
it
do i believe like there's a reason why
there's so much more dystopic sci-fi
than topic sci-fi and the in the some
pro topic sci-fi
usually requires magic is because
or at least magical tech right dilithium
crystals and warp drives and stuff
because it's very hard to imagine
people like the people we have been in
the history books
with exponential type
technology and power that don't
eventually blow themselves up
that make good enough choices as
stewards of their environment and their
comments and
and each other and etc so like it's
easier to think of scenarios where we
blow ourselves up than it is to think of
scenarios where we avoid every single
scenario where we blow ourselves up
and when i say blow ourselves up i also
i mean the environmental versions
the terrorist versions the war versions
the cumulative externalities
versions um
can i and i'm sorry if i'm interrupting
your flow of thought
but why is it easier is it could be a
weird psychological thing where we
either was just more capable to
visualize explosions and destruction
and then the sicker thought which is
like we kind of enjoy
for some weird reason thinking about
that kind of stuff even though we
wouldn't actually
act on it it's almost like some weird uh
like i love playing shooter games
you know uh first person shooters and
like
especially if it's like murdering zombie
and doom
you're shooting demons i played one of
my favorite games
diablo is like slashing through
different monsters and the screaming and
pain and the hellfire
and then i go out into the real world uh
to eat my coconut ice cream and i'm all
about love
so like i can we trust our ability to
visualize how all it all goes to [ __ ]
as an actual rational way of thinking i
think it's a
fair question to say to what degree is
there just kind of
perverse fantasy and
morbid exploration and whatever else
that happens in our imagination
uh but i don't think that's the whole of
it
i think there is also a reality to the
combinatorial possibility space
and the difference in the probabilities
that there's a lot of ways i could try
to put
the 70 trillion cells of your body
together that don't make you
there's not that many ways i can put
them together that make you there's a
lot of ways i can try to connect the
organs together that make some weird
kind of
group of organs on a on a desk but that
doesn't actually make a functioning
human and and you can kill an adult
human in a second but you can't get one
in a second takes
20 years to grow one and a lot of things
to happen right i could destroy this
building
in a couple minutes with demolition
but it took a year or a couple years to
build it there is
uh there's outdone coal this is just an
example it's not he doesn't mean it
there's a there's a gradient where
entropy is easier
and there's a lot more ways to put a set
of things together that don't work than
the few that really do produce higher
order synergies
and so
when we look at a history of war and
then we look at
exponentially more powerful warfare an
arms race that drives that in all these
directions
and when we look at a history of
environmental destruction and
exponentially more powerful tech that
makes exponential externalities
multiplied by the total number of agents
that are doing it in the cumulative
effects
there's a lot of ways the whole thing
can break like a lot of different ways
and for it to get ahead it has to have
none of those happen
and so there's just a probability space
where it's easier to imagine that thing
so
what so to say how do we have a protopic
future we have to say well
one criteria must be that it avoids all
of the catastrophic risks
so can we understand can we inventory
all the catastrophic risks can we
inventory the patterns of human behavior
that give rise to them
and could we try to solve for that and
could we have that be
the the essence of the social technology
that we're thinking about to be able to
guide bind and direct a new physical
technology because so far our physical
technology
like we were talking about the genghis
khans and like that that obviously use
certain kinds of physical
technology and armaments um and also
social technology and unconventional
warfare
for a particular set of purposes but we
have things that don't look like warfare
like rockefeller and standard oil
and it looked like a constructive
mindset
to be able to bring this new energy
resource
to the world and it did and the second
order effects of that
are climate change
and all of the oil spills that have
happened and will happen
and all of the wars in the middle east
over the oil that have been there
and the massive political [ __ ]
and human life issues that are
associated with it and
on and on right um and so
it's also not just
the orientation to construct a thing can
have a narrow focus on what i'm trying
to construct but be affecting a lot of
other things through second and
third-order effects i'm not taking
responsibility for
and you you you often another and
another tangent
mentioned second third and fourth order
effects
and order and and skating which is
really fascinating like starting with
the third order
plus it gets really interesting
because we we don't we don't even
acknowledge like the second order
effects
right but like thinking because those it
could mat
it could get bigger and bigger and
bigger in ways we're not anticipating
so how do we make those so it sounds
like part of the
part of the thing that you are thinking
through in terms of a solution
how to create an anti-fray agile a
resilient society
is to make explicit
acknowledge understand the externalities
the second order
third order fourth order and the order
effects
how do we start to think about those
effects
yeah the war application is harm we're
trying to cause or that we're aware
we're causing right
um the externality is harm that at least
supposedly we're not aware we're causing
or at minimum it's not our intention
right maybe we're either totally unaware
of it or we're aware of it but
it is a side effect of what our
intention is it's not the intention
itself
there are catastrophic risks from both
types the direct application
of increased technological power to a
rivalrous intent
which is going to cause harm for some
out group for some in-group to win
but the out group is also working on
growing the tech and if they don't lose
completely they reverse engineer the tac
up regulator come back with more
capacity so there's the exponential tech
arms race
side of in-group out-group rivalry using
exponential tech that is one set of
risks
and the other set of risks is
the application of exponentially more
powerful tech
not intentionally to try and beat an out
group but to try to achieve some goal
that we have but that produces second
and third order effects
that do have harm to the commons to
other people to
environment to other groups
that might actually be bigger problems
than the problem we were originally
trying to solve with the thing we were
building
when facebook was building a dating app
and then building a social app where
people could tag pictures
they weren't trying to build a democracy
destroying app
uh that would maximize time on site
as part of its ad model through ai
optimization of a news feed to the thing
that made people spend most time on site
which is usually them being limbically
hijacked more than
something else which ends up appealing
to people's cognitive biases and group
identities
and creates no sense of shared reality
they weren't trying to do that but it
was a second order effect
and it's a pretty [ __ ] powerful
second order effect
um and a pretty fast one because the
rate of tech is obviously
able to get distributed to much larger
scale much faster and
with a bigger jump in terms of total
vertical capacity then that's what it
means to get to the verticalizing part
of an exponential curve
so um just like we can see
that oil had these second order
environmental effects and also social
and political effects
war and so much of the whole
like the total amount of oil used is
has a proportionality to total global
gdp
and that's why we have this you know the
petrodollar and um
and so the the oil thing also had the
externalities of a major aspect of what
happened with military industrial
complex and things like that
so but we can see the same thing with
with
more current technologies with facebook
and google and
other things so i don't think we can run
and the more powerful the tech is we
build it for
reason x whatever reason x is maybe x is
three things maybe it's one thing
right we we're doing the oil thing
because we want to make
cars because it's a better method of
individual transportation we're building
the facebook thing because we're going
to connect people socially in a personal
sphere
but it it interferes with it interacts
with complex systems
with ecologies economies psychologies
cultures and so it has effects on other
than the thing we're intending
some of those effects can end up being
negative effects but because this
technology
if if we make it to solve a problem it
has to overcome the problem the
problem's been around for a while it's
going to overcome in a short period of
time so it usually has
greater scale greater rate of magnitude
in some way
that also means that the externalities
that it creates might be bigger problems
and you can say well but then that's the
new problem humanity will innovate its
way out of that
well i don't think that's paying
attention to the fact that we can't keep
up with exponential curves
like that nor do finite spaces allow
exponential externalities forever
and this is why a lot of the smartest
people thinking about this are
thinking well no i think we're totally
screwed and
unless we can make a benevolent ai
singleton that rules all of us
um you know guys like bostrom and and
others
uh thinking in those directions because
they're like how do
humans try to do multi-polarity
and make it work and i i have a
different answer
of what i think it looks like that does
have more to do with the
love but some applied social tech
alignment aligned with
good because i have a bunch of really
dumb ideas
i prefer to uh i'd like to hear i'd like
to hear some of them first
i think the idea i would have is uh to
be a bit more rigorous
in trying to measure the amount of
love you add or subtract from the world
in
second third fourth fifth order effects
it's actually i think especially in the
world of tech
quite doable you know you just might not
like
you know the the shareholders may not
like that kind of metric
but it's pretty easy to measure like
that's not even uh
i'm perhaps half joking about love but
we could talk about just happiness and
well-being
long-term well-being it's pretty easy
for facebook for youtube for all these
companies to measure that they do a lot
of kinds of surveys they could do i mean
there's very simple solutions here
that you could just survey how i mean
servers are in some sense use useless
because they're
um a subset of the population you're
just trying to get a sense it's very
loose kind of understanding
but integrated deeply as part of the
technology most of our tech is
recommender systems most of the
sorry not tech uh online interactions
driven by recommender systems that
learn very little data about you and use
that data
based on mostly based on traces your
previous behavior to suggest
future things this is how twitter is how
facebook works this is how
adsense for google adsense works is how
netflix youtube work and so on
and and for them to just track as
opposed to engagement
how much you spend in a particular video
a particular site
is also track give you the technology to
do
self-report of what makes you feel good
what makes you grow as a person
of what makes you uh
you know the best version of yourself
the the the rogan uh idea of the hero of
your movie
and just add that little bit of
information
if you you have people you have this
like happiness surveys of
how you feel about the last five days
how would you report your experience
you can lay out the set of videos this
is kind of fascinating
i don't know if you ever look at youtube
the history of videos you've looked at
it's fascinating it's very embarrassing
for me like
it'll be like a lecture and then like a
set of videos
that i don't want anyone to know about
which is
which which will be like i don't know
maybe like five videos in a row where it
looks like i watched the whole thing
which i probably did about like how to
cook a steak
even though or just like with the best
chefs in the world cooking steaks and
i'm just like
sitting there watching it for no purpose
whatsoever wasting away my life
or like funny cat videos or like legit
that that doesn't that's always a good
one and i could look back
and rate which videos made me a better
person and not
and i mean on a more serious note
there's a bunch of conversations
podcasts or
lectures i've watched which made me a
better person
and some of it made me a worse person
quite honestly
not for stupid reasons like i feel
dumber but because i do
have a sense that that started me on a
path
of
of not being kind to other people for
example i'll give you
uh for my own and i'm sorry for ranting
but maybe there's some usefulness to
this kind of exploration of self
when i focus on creating on programming
on science i become
a much deeper thinker and a kinder
person to others
when i listen to too many a little bit
as good but too many
podcasts or videos about how how our
world is melting down
or criticizing ridiculous people the
worst of the quote unquote woke
for example all there's all these groups
that are misbehaving in fascinating ways
because they've been corrupted by power
the more i want the more i watch
criticism
of them the worse i become
and i'm aware of this but i'm also aware
that
for some reason it's pleasant to watch
those sometimes
and so for for me to be able to
self-report that to the youtube
algorithm
to the systems around me and they
ultimately try to optimize
to make me the best person the best
version of myself
which i personally believe would make
youtube a lot more money because i'd be
much more willing to spend time on
youtube and give
youtube a lot more a lot more of my
money
that's a that's great for business and
great for humanity because it'll make me
a kinder person
it'll increase the the love quotient
the love metric and uh it'll make them a
lot of money i feel like everything is
aligned
and so you should do that not just for
youtube algorithm but also for our
military strategy and whether to go to
war or not
because one externality you can think of
about going to war
which i think we talked about offline is
we often go to
war with kind of governments with a uh
with
not with the people you have to think
about
the kids of countries
that see a soldier and
because of what they experienced their
interaction with the soldier
hate is born when you're like eight
years old
six years old you lose your dad you lose
your mom
you lose a friend somebody close to you
that want a
really powerful externality that could
be reduced to love
positive and negative is uh
the hate that's born when you make
decisions and that's going to
take fruition that that little seed is
going to become a tree that then leads
to the kind of destruction
that we talk about
so but my sense it's possible to reduce
everything to a measure of how much love
does this add to the world
all that to say uh do you have ideas of
how we practically
uh build systems
that that create a resilient society
there are a lot of good things that you
shared where there's like
15 different ways that we could enter
this that are all interesting so i'm
trying to see which one will probably be
most useful pick the uh
the one or two things that are at least
ridiculous when you're mentioning
if we could see some of the
second order effects or externalities
that we aren't used to seeing
specifically the one
of a kid being radicalized somewhere
else which engenders enmity in them
towards us which decreases our own
future security
even if you don't care about the kid if
you care about the kids the whole other
thing
um yeah i mean i think when
we saw this when jane fonda and others
went to vietnam and took
photos and videos of what was happening
and you got to see the pictures of
the kids with napalm on them uh
that like the anti-war effort was
bolstered by that in a way it couldn't
have been without that there's
there's a until we can see the images
you can't have a mere neuron
effect in the same way and when you can
that starts to have a
powerful effect i think there's a deep
principle that you're
sharing there which is
that if we we can have a rivalrous
intent
where our in-group whatever it is maybe
it's our political party wanting to win
within the u.s
maybe it's our nation state wanting to
win in a
a war or an economic war over resource
or whatever it is
that if we don't obliterate the other
people completely
they don't go away they're they're not
engendered to like us more
they didn't become less smart so they
have more enmity towards us and whatever
technologies we employ to be successful
they will now reverse
engineer make iterations on and come
back
and so you drive an arms race which is
why you can see
that the wars were over
history employing more lethal weaponry
and not just the kinetic war um
the information war and the narrative
war and the
economic war right like it just
increased capacity in all of those
fronts
um and so what seems like a win to us
on the short term might actually really
produce losses in the long term
and what's even in our own best interest
in the long term is probably more
aligned with everyone else because we
inter-affect each other
and i think the thing about globalism
globalization
and exponential tech and the rate at
which we affect each other and the rate
at which we affect the biosphere that
we're all affected by
is that this this kind of
proverbial spiritual idea that we're all
interconnected and need to think about
that in some way
it was easy for tribes to get because
everyone in the tribe
so clearly saw their interconnection and
dependence on each other
but in terms of a global level the
the speed at which we are actually
interconnected the speed at which the
harm happening to something in
wuhan affects the rest of the world or a
new technology developed somewhere
affects the entire world or an
environmental issue or whatever
is making it to where we either actually
all get
not as a spiritual idea just even as
physics right we all get
the interconnectedness of everything and
that we either all consider that and see
how to make it through more effectively
together
or failures anywhere end up becoming
decreased quality of life and failures
and increased risk everywhere don't you
think people are beginning to experience
that at the
individual level so governments are
resisting it they're they're trying to
make us not empathize with each other
feel connected but don't you think
people are beginning to feel more and
more connected
like isn't that exactly what the
technology is enabling like social
networks we tend to criticize them but
isn't there a sense which were
experience you know when you watch those
videos
that are criticizing whether it's the
woke antifa side
or the q anon trump supporter side
does it seem like they have increased
empathy for people that are outside of
their ideological not at all
so i may be um
i may be conflating my own experience of
the world
and that of uh
that of the populace i i tend to see
those videos
as feeding something that's a relic of
the past
they figured out that drama fuels clicks
but whether i'm right or wrong i don't
know but i
tend to sense that that is not
that hunger for drama is not fundamental
to human beings
that we want to actually
that we want to understand antifa and we
want to
like empathize we want to take radical
ideas
and be able to empathize with them and
synthesize it all
okay let's look at
cultural outliers in terms of
violence versus compassion we can see
that a lot of cultures have
relatively lower in-group violence
bigger out-group violence and there's
some variants in them and variants at
different times based on the scarcity or
abundance of resource and other things
but you can look at say
jane's whose whole religion is around
non-violence so much so that they don't
even hurt plants they only take fruits
that fall off them and stuff
or to go to a larger population you take
buddhists
where for the most part with a few
exceptions for the most part across
three millennia
and across lots of different countries
and geographies and whatever
you have 10 million people plus or minus
who don't hurt bugs
the whole spectrum of genetic variants
that is happening within a culture of
that many people
um and head traumas and whatever and
nobody hurts bugs
and then you look at a group where the
kids grow up as child soldiers in
liberia or darfur
where to make it to adulthood pretty
much everybody's killed people
hand-to-hand
and killed people who were civilian or
innocent type of people
and you say okay so we were very neonos
we can be conditioned by our environment
and humans can
be conditioned where almost all the
humans show up in these two different
bell curves it doesn't mean that the
buddhists had no violence it doesn't
mean that these people had no compassion
but the
they're very different gaussian
distributions
and so i think one of the important
things
that i like to do is look at the
examples of the
populations what buddhism shows
regarding compassion or what
judaism shows around education the
average level of education that
everybody gets because of a culture that
is really working on conditioning it or
various cultures what are the positive
deviants
outside of this statistical deviance to
see
what is actually possible and then say
what are the
conditioning factors and can we
condition those across a few of them
simultaneously
and could we build a civilization like
that becomes a very
interesting question so there's this
kind of real politic idea that
humans are violent large groups of
humans become
violent they become irrational
specifically those two things rivalrous
and violent and irrational
and so in order to minimize the total
amount of violence and have some good
decisions they need ruled somehow
and that not getting that is some kind
of naive utopianism that doesn't
understand
human nature yet this gets back to like
mimesis of desire as an inexorable thing
i think the idea of the masses is
actually a kind of propaganda
um that is useful for the classes that
control
um to popularize the idea that most
people are too violent lazy
undisciplined and irrational to make
good choices
and therefore their choices should be
sublimated in some kind of way
i think that if we look back at these
conditioning environments
we can say okay so the kids
they go to
a really fancy school and have a good
developmental environment like exeter
academy
there's still a gaussian distribution of
how well they do on any particular
metric
but on average they become senators and
the worst ones become high-end lawyers
or whatever
and then i look at an inner city school
with a totally different set of things
and i see a very very differently
displaced gaussian distribution but very
different set of conditioning factors so
then i say the masses well if all those
kids who were one of the parts of the
masses got to go to exeter and have that
family and whatever would they still be
the masses
could we actually condition
more social virtue more civic virtue
more orientation towards dialectical
synthesis
more empathy more rationality widely
yes would that lead to
better capacity for something like
participatory governance democracy or
republic or some kind of participatory
governance
yes yes is it necessary for it actually
yes and is it good for class interests
not not really by the way when you say
class interest
this is the powerful leading over the
less powerful that kind of idea
anyone that benefits from asymmetries of
power
doesn't necessarily benefit from
decreasing those asymmetries of power
and kind of increasing the capacity of
people more widely and
um so when we talk about
power we're talking about asymmetries
and agency influence and control
you think that hunger for power is
fundamental to human nature
i i think we should get that straight
before we talk about other stuff so like
uh
this uh this this pickup line that i use
at a bar off
which is uh power corrupts and absolute
power crops absolutely
is that true or is that just a fancy
thing to say
in modern society there's something to
be said have we changed as societies
over time
in terms of how much we crave power that
there is an
impulse towards power that is innate in
people and can be conditioned one way or
the other yes but you can see that
buddhist society does a very different
thing with it at scale
that you don't end up seeing the
emergence of
the same types of sociopathic behavior
and particularly then creating
sociopathic institutions
um and so it's like
is eating the foods that were rare in
our evolutionary environment that give
us more dopamine hit because they were
rare and they're not anymore salt fat
sugar
um is there something pleasurable about
those where humans have an orientation
to overeat if they can well the fact
that there is that possibility doesn't
mean everyone will obligately be obese
and die of obesity right like
it's possible to have a uh
a particular impulse and to be able to
understand it have other ones and be
able to balance them
and so to say that um
power dynamics are are obligate in
humans and we can't do anything about it
is very similar to me to saying like
we could everyone is going to be
obligately obese yeah so there's some
degree to which those
the control those impulses has to do
with the conditioning early in life
yes and the culture that creates the
environment to be able to do that
and then the recursion on that okay so
what if we were to uh
just bear with me just asking for a
friend if we were to kill all humans on
earth
and then start over
is there ideas about how to build up
okay we don't have to kill let's leave
the humans on earth they're fine
and go to mars and start a new society
is there ways to construct systems of
conditioning
education of how we live with each other
that would um that would
incentivize us properly to not seek
power
not to not construct systems that are
of asymmetry of power and to create
systems that are resilient to all kinds
of terrorist attacks
to all kinds of destructions
i believe so so is there some inklings
we'll get
of course you probably don't have the
ant all the answers but you have
insights about what that looks like i
mean is it just rigorous practice of
dialectic
synthesis as essentially conversations
with [ __ ] of various flavors until
they're not [ __ ] anymore because
you've become
deeply apathetic with their experience
okay so
there's a lot of things that we
would need to construct to come back to
this like what is the basis of rivalry
what
how do you bind it how does it relate to
tech
if you have a culture that is doing less
rivalry does it always
lose in war to those who do war better
and how do you make something on the
enactment of how to get there from here
um great great so what's rivalry why is
rivalry bad or good
is is so is another word for our very
competition
yes i think roughly yes i think
bad and good are kind of silly concepts
here
good for some things bad for other
things for some contexts and others
even that um okay let me give you an
example that relates back to the
facebook measuring thing you were
mentioning a moment ago
first i think what you're saying is
actually aligned with the right
direction and what i want to get to in a
moment
um but it's not the devil is in the
details here
so i i enjoy praise feeds my ego i grow
stronger
so i appreciate that i'll make sure to
include one piece every 15 minutes as we
thank you
so
it's easier to measure
there are problems with this argument
but there's also utility to it so let's
take it
for the utility it has first
it's harder to measure happiness than it
is to measure comfort
we can measure with technology that the
shocks in a car are making the car
bounce less that the bed is um softer
and
you know material science and those
types of things and happiness
is actually hard for philosophers to
define because
some people find that there's certain
kinds of overcoming suffering that are
necessary for happiness there's
happiness it feels more like contentment
and happiness it feels more like passion
that's
is passion the source of all suffering
or the source of all creativity like the
there's deep stuff and it's mostly first
person not measurable third-person stuff
even if maybe it corresponds to
third-person stuff to some degree but we
also see examples of
some of our favorite examples is people
who are in the worst environments who
end up finding happiness right where the
third-person stuff looks to be less
conducive and there's some victor frankl
nelson mandela whatever
but it's pretty easy to measure comfort
and it's pretty universal and
i think we can see that the industrial
revolution started to replace
happiness with comfort quite heavily as
the thing it was optimizing for and we
can see that when increased comfort
is given maybe because of the
evolutionary disposition
that expending extra calories when for
the majority of our history we didn't
have extra calories was not a
safe thing to do who knows why
when extra comfort is given it's very
easy
to take that path even if it's not the
path that supports overall well-being
long term
and so we can see that
you know when you when you look at the
techno-optimist idea that we have better
lives than
egyptian pharaohs and kings and whatever
what they're largely looking at
is how comfortable our beds are
and how comfortable the transportation
systems are and things like that in
which case there's massive
improvement but we also see that in some
of the nations where people have access
to the most comfort suicide and mental
illness are the highest
and we also see that some of the
happiest cultures
are actually some of the ones that are
in materially lame environments
and so there's a very interesting
question here and if i
understand correctly you do cold showers
and joe rogan was talking about how he
needs to do some fairly intensive kind
of
struggle that is a non-comfort to
actually induce
being better as a person this concept of
hormesis
that it's actually stressing an adaptive
system that increases its adaptive
capacity
and that there's something that the
happiness of a system has something to
do with its adaptive capacity its
overall resilience health well-being
which requires a decent bit of
discomfort and
yet in the in the presence of the
comfort solution it's very hard to not
choose it and then as you're choosing it
regularly to actually down regulate your
overall adaptive capacity
and so when we start saying can we
make tech where we're measuring for the
things that it produces beyond just
the measure of gdp or whatever
particular
measures look like the revenue
generation or profit generation of my
business
are all the meaningful things measurable
and what are the right measures and what
are the externalities of optimizing for
that measurement set what meaningful
things aren't included in that
measurement set they might have their
own externalities
these are some of the questions we
actually have to take seriously yeah and
i think they're answerable questions
right progressively better not perfect
right so so first of all let me throw
out happiness and comfort out of the
discussion those seems like useless
the distinction so i because i said
they're useful well-being is useful but
i think i i take it back
i knew uh i proposed new metrics
in this brainstorm session which is uh
so one is like personal growth
which is intellectual growth i think
we're able to
make that concrete for ourselves like
you're a better person than you were a
week ago
or a worse person than you were a week
ago i think we can
ourselves report that and and and
understand what that means is this gray
area
and we try to define it but i think we
humans are pretty good at that
because we have a sense an idealistic
sense of the person we might be able to
become we
we all dream of becoming a certain kind
of person and i think we have a sense
of getting closer and not towards that
person maybe this is not a great metric
fine
the other one is love actually
[ __ ] if you're happy or not or you're
comfortable or not
how much love do you have towards your
fellow human beings
i feel like if you try to optimize that
and increasing that
that's going to have that's a good
metric
how many times a day sorry if i can make
quantify how many times a day have you
thought positively of another human
being
just put that down as a number and
increase that number
i think the process of saying okay so
let's not take gdp or gdp per capita as
the metric we want to optimize for
because gdp goes up during war and it
goes up with more health care spending
from sicker people and various things
that we wouldn't say correlate to
quality of life
uh addiction drives gdp awesomely um
by the way when i said growth i wasn't
referred to
i'm giving an example now of the primary
metric we use and why it's not not
equipment
because we're exploring other ones so
the idea of saying what would the
metrics
for a good civilization be if i had to
pick a set of metrics what would the
best ones be if i was going to optimize
for those
and then really try to run the thought
experiment
more deeply and say okay so what happens
if we optimize for that
try to think through the first and
second and third order effects
of what happens it's positive and then
also say
what negative things can happen from
optimizing that what actually matters it
is not included in that or in that way
of defining it because love versus
number of positive thoughts per day i
could just make a long list of names and
just think say positive thing about each
one it's all very superficial
not include animals or the rest of life
have a have a very
shallow total amount of it but i'm
optimizing the number and if i get some
credit for the number
so the and this is when i said the model
of reality isn't reality
when you make a set of metrics they were
going to optimize for this
whatever reality is that is not included
in those metrics can be the areas where
harm occurs which is why
i would say that wisdom is something
like
the discernment that leads to right
choices
beyond what metrics based optimization
would offer yeah
but another way to say that is
wisdom is uh constantly
expanding and evolving set of metrics
so which means there is something in you
that is recognizing a new metric
that's important that isn't part of that
metric set so there's a certain kind of
connection discernment awareness
and this is this is iterative game
theory there's a girdles in completeness
theorem right which is if the system if
the set of things is consistent it won't
be complete so we're going to keep
adding to it which is
why we were saying earlier i don't think
it's not beautiful
and especially if you were just saying
one of the metrics you want to optimize
for at the individual level is becoming
right they were becoming more well
that's zen becomes true for the
civilization and our metric sets as well
yeah and our definition of how to think
about a meaningful
life in a meaningful civilization i can
tell you what some of my favorite
metrics are
what's that
uh well love is obviously not a metric
it's like you can bench
yeah it's a good metric yeah i want to
optimize that across the entire
population starting with infants
um so
in the same way that love isn't metric
but you could make metrics that look at
certain parts of it this thing i'm about
to say isn't the metric but it's a it's
a consideration
because i thought about this a lot i i
don't think there is a metric a right
one
um i think that every metric by itself
without this thing we talked about of
the continuous improvement becomes a
paperclip maximizer
i think that's why what the idea of
false idol
means in terms of the model of reality
not being reality
then my sacred relationship is to
reality itself which also binds me to
the unknown forever
to the known but also to the unknown and
there's a sense of sacredness
connected to the unknown that creates an
epistemic humility that is always
seeking not just to optimize the thing i
know but to learn new stuff
and to be open to perceive reality
directly so my model never becomes
sacred my model is useful
the model can't be the false idol
correct yeah
and this is why the first verse of the
tao te ching is the dao that is nameable
is not the eternal dao
the naming then can become the source of
the ten thousand things that if you get
too
carried away with it can actually
obscure you from paying attention to
reality beyond in
the models it sounds a lot a lot like
steven wolfram but in a different
language much more poetic i can imagine
that
no i'm referring to i'm joking but
there's
echoes of cellular automata which you
can't name you can't construct a good
model cellular automata
you can only watch in awe i apologize
i'm distracting your train of thought
horribly and miserably making it by the
way something robots aren't good at
in uh dealing with the uncertainty of
uneven ground you've been
okay so far you've been doing
wonderfully so what's your favorite
metrics
okay so i know you're not wrong so i
haven't passed anything test so one
metric
and there are problems with this but one
metric that i like to just
as a thought experiment to consider is
because you're actually asking work i
mean i know you ask your guests
about the meaning of life because
ultimately when you're designing when
you're saying what is a desirable
civilization you can't answer that
without answering
what is a meaningful human life and to
say what is a good civilization
because it's going to be in relationship
to that right
um
and then you have whatever your answer
is how do you know what is the
what is the epistemic basis for for
postulating that
um there's also a whole other reason for
asking that question
i don't i mean but that doesn't even
apply to you
whatsoever which is it's interesting how
few people have been
asked questions like it
we we we joke about these questions is
silly
right it's it's funny to watch a person
and if i was more of an [ __ ] i would
really stick on that question
right it's a silly question in some
sense but
like we haven't really considered what
it means just
a more concrete version of that question
is what is what is a better world
what is the kind of world we're trying
to create really i think well have you
really thought
i'll give you some kind of simple
answers to that that are meaningful to
me
but let me do the societal indices first
because they're fun yes
we should take a note of this meaningful
thing because it's important to come
back to
are you reminding me to ask you about
the meaning of life noted
let me jot that down yeah so um
well because i think i stopped tracking
it like 25 open threads
um okay let it all burn one
index that i find very interesting is
the inverse correlation of addiction
within the society
the more a society produces addiction
within the people
in it the less healthy i think the
society is
as a pretty fundamental metric and so
the more the individuals feel that there
are less
compulsive things in
compelling them to behave in ways that
are destructive to their own values
uh and in so far as a civilization is
conditioning and influencing the
individuals within it
the inverse of addiction uh
yeah compulsive behavior that is
destructive towards
things that we value
yeah i think that's a very interesting
one to think that's a really interesting
one yeah
and this is then also where comfort and
addiction start to get very close
and the ability to go in the other
direction from addiction is the ability
to be exposed to hypernormal stimuli and
not
go down the path of desensitizing to
other stimuli and needing that
hypernormal stimuli
which does involve a kind of hormesis so
i do think the civilization of the
future has to create
something like ritualized discomfort
and um
virtualized discomfort yeah i think
that's what the sweat lodge
and the vision quest and the solo
journey and the ayahuasca journey and
the sundance were
i think it's even a big part of what
yoga asana was
is to make beings that are resilient and
strong they have to overcome some things
to make beings that can control their
own mind and fear they have to face some
fears
but we don't want to put everybody in
war or real trauma
and yet we can see that the most [ __ ]
up people we know
had childhoods of a lot of trauma but
some of the most incredible people we
know had childhoods have a lot of trauma
whether or not they happen to make it
through and overcome that or not
so how do we get the benefits of the
stealing of character and the resilience
and the whatever that happened from the
difficulty without traumatizing people
a certain kind of ritualized discomfort
that not only has us overcome something
by ourselves but overcome it together
with each other where nobody bails when
it gets hard because the other people
are there so it's both a resilience of
the individuals and the resilience of
the bonding
so i think we'll keep getting more and
more comfortable stuff but we have to
also
develop resilience in the presence of
that
for the anti-addiction direction and the
fullness of character
and the trustworthiness to others so you
have to be uh
consistently injecting discomfort into
the system ritualize
i mean this sounds like uh you have to
imagine sisyphus happy
you have to uh imagine sisyphus with his
rock
optimally resilient from a metrics
perspective
in society so we we want
we want to constantly be throwing rocks
at ourselves
not constantly uh you didn't have to
frequently
um periodically periodically and there's
different levels of intensity different
periodicities now i do not think this
should be imposed by states i think it
should emerge from cultures
and i think the cultures are developing
people that understand the value of it
so the people
so there is both a cultural cohesion to
it but there's also a voluntarism
because the people value
the thing that is being developed they
understand it and that's what conditions
is conditioning
it's conditioning some of these some of
these values and
conditioning is a bad word because we
like our idea of sovereignty but when we
recognize
the language that we speak and the words
that we think and in the
in the patterns of thought built into
that language and the aesthetics that we
like and so much is conditioned
in us just based on where we're born you
can't not condition people so all you
can do is take more responsibility for
what the conditioning factors are and
then you have to think about this
question of what is a meaningful human
life because we're
unlike the other animals born into
environment that they're genetically
adapted for we're building new
environments that we were
not adapted for and then we're becoming
affected by those so then we have to say
well what kinds of environments digital
environments physical environments
social environments
would we want to create that would
develop the
healthiest happiest most moral noble
meaningful people
and what are even those sets of things
that matter so you end up getting
deep existential consideration at the
heart of civilization design when you
start to realize how powerful we're
becoming and how much
what we're building it in service
towards matters before i pull it
i think three threads you just laid down
uh is there another
metric index that you're interested i'll
tell you one more that i really like
there's a there's a number but one then
the next one that comes to mind is
i have to make a very quick model uh
healthy human bonding say we were in a
travel type setting
my positive emotional states in your
positive emotional states
would most of the time be correlated
your negative emotional states in mine
and so you start laughing i start
laughing you start crying
my eyes might tear up and
we would call that the compassion
compersion axis i would this is
a model i i find useful so compassion is
when you're feeling something negative i
feel some pain i feel some empathy
something in relationship
compersion is when you do well i'm
stoked for you right like
i actually feel happiness i like
compersion
yeah the fact that it's such a uncommon
word in english is actually a problem
culturally
um because i feel that often and i think
that's a really good feeling to feel
and maximize for actually that's
actually the metric i'm going to say oh
wow
is the compassion compersion at axis is
the thing i would optimize for
now there is a state where my
emotional states in your emotional
states are just totally decoupled
and that is like sociopathy i don't want
to hurt you but i don't care if i do or
for you to do well or whatever
but there's a worse state and it's
extremely common which is where they're
inversely coupled where
my positive emotions correspond to your
negative ones and vice versa
and that is the i i would call it the
jealousy sadism axis
the jealousy axis is when you're doing
really well i feel something bad
i feel taken away from less than upset
envious whatever and
that's so common
but i think of it as kind of a low-grade
psychopathology
that we've just normalized the idea that
i'm actually
upset at the happiness or fulfillment or
success of another is like a profoundly
[ __ ] up thing
no we shouldn't shame it and repress it
so it gets worse we should study it
where does it come from and it comes
from our own insecurities and stuff
and but then the next part that
everybody knows is really [ __ ] up
is just on the same axis it's the same
inverted which is
so the jealousy or the envy is the i
feel badly when
you're doing well the sadism side is i
actually feel good when you lose
or when you're in pain i feel some
happiness that's associated you can see
when someone feels jealous
sometimes they feel jealous with a
partner and then they feel
they want that partner to get it revenge
comes up or something
so sadism is really like jealousy is one
step
on the path to sadism from the healthy
compassion conversion access so
i would like to see a society that is
inversely
that is conditioning sadism and jealousy
inversely right the lower that amount
and the more the compassion conversion
and if i had to summarize that very
simply i'd say it would optimize for
conversion
which is because notice that's not just
saying love
for you where i might be
self-sacrificing and miserable and
i love people but i kill myself which i
don't think anybody thinks a great idea
or happiness where i might be
sociopathically happy where i'm
causing problems all over the place or
even sadistically happy
but it's a coupling right that i'm
actually feeling happiness in
relationship to yours and even in causal
relationship where i
my own agentic desire to get happier
wants to support you too
that's actually speaking of another
pickup line uh
that's quite honestly what i this is a
guy who's single this is
this is going to come out very
ridiculous because it's like oh yeah
where's your girlfriend bro
but that's what i look for in a
relationship
because it's like it's so much it's so
it's such an amazing life where you
actually get joy from another person's
success
and they get joy from your success and
then it becomes like
you don't actually need to succeed much
for that to have a like a
a a like a cycle of just like happiness
that just increases like exponentially
it's weird
so like just be just enjoying the the
happiness of others the success of
others
so this this is like the uh let's call
this because the first person that
drilled this into my head is rogan
joe rogan here's the embodiment of that
because i saw somebody who was uh
successful rich
and non-stop truly i mean you could tell
when somebody's full of [ __ ]
somebody's not really genuinely enjoying
the success of his friends
that that was weird to me that was
interesting and i mean the way you're
kind of
speaking to it the reason joe stood out
to me
is i guess i haven't witnessed genuine
expression of that often in this culture
of just real joy for others
i mean part of that has to do there
hasn't been many channels where you can
watch or listen to people being their
authentic cells
so i'm sure there's a bunch of people
who live life with compersion they
probably
don't seek public attention also but the
that that was yeah if if there was any
word that could express what what i've
learned from joan white he's been a
a really inspiring figure is that
compersion and i wish our world
was uh had a lot more of that
because then it me i mean my own
so sorry to go on a small tangent but
like
you're speaking how society should
function
but i feel like if you optimize for that
metric in your own personal life
you're going to uh live a
truly fulfilling life i don't know what
the right word to use
but that's a really good way to live
life you will also
learn what gets in the way of it right
and how to work with it that if you
wanted to help try to build systems at
scale or apply facebook or exponential
technologies to do that you would have
more actual depth of real knowledge of
what that takes
and this is you know as you mentioned
that there's this virtuous cycle between
when you get stoked on other people
doing well and then they have a similar
relationship to you and everyone is in
the process of building each other up
and this is what i would say the healthy
version of competition is
versus the unhealthy version the healthy
version right the
the root i believe it's a latin word
that means to strive together
and it's that impulse of becoming where
i want to become more but i recognize
that there's actually a hormesis there's
a challenge that is needed
for me to be able to do that but that
means that
yes there's an impulse where i'm trying
to get ahead maybe i'm even trying to
win but i actually want a good opponent
and i want them to get ahead too because
that is where my ongoing becoming
happens and the win itself will get
boring very quickly
the ongoing becoming is where there's
aliveness and for the ongoing becoming
they need to have it too
and that's the stride together the so in
the healthy competition i'm stoked when
they're doing really well
because my becoming is supported by it
now this is actually a very nice segue
into
a model i like about what a meaningful
human life is
if you want to go there
let's go there well i have
i have three things i'm going elsewhere
with but if we were first
let us take a short stroll through the
park of the meaning of life
daniel what is a meaningful life
i think the semantics end up mattering
because a lot of people
will take the word meaning and the word
purpose
almost interchangeably and they'll talk
they'll think kind of what is the
meaning of my life what is the meaning
of human life what is the meaning of
life what's the meaning of the universe
and what what is the meaning of
existence rather than non-existent so
there's
a lot of kind of existential
considerations there and i think there's
some cognitive mistakes that are very
easy like taking
the idea of purpose which is like a goal
which is a utilitarian concept the
purpose of one thing is defined in
relationship to other things that have
assumed value
um and to say what is the purpose of
everything
well it's a purpose is too small of a
question it's fundamentally a relative
question within everything what is the
purpose of one thing relative to another
what is the purpose of everything and
there's nothing outside of it with which
to say it
you actually just got to the limits of
the utility of the
concept of purpose it doesn't mean it's
purposeless in the sense of something
inside of it being purposeless it means
the concept is too small
which is why you end up getting to you
know like in taoism talking about
the nature of it rather the there's a
fundamental what
where the why can't go deeper is the
nature of it
but i'm gonna try to speak to a much
simpler
part which is when people think about
what is a meaningful human life
and kind of if we were to optimize for
something at the level of individual
life
but also how does optimizing for this at
the level of the individual life
lead to the best
society for insofar as people living
that way affects others
and long-term the world as a whole and
how would we then
make a civilization that was trying to
think about these things
because you can see that there are a lot
of dialectics where
there's value on two sides individualism
and collectivism or
the ability to accept things and the
ability to push harder and whatever
and there's failure modes on both sides
and so when you're starting to say okay
individual happiness you're like wait
[ __ ] sadists can be happy while hurting
people it's not individual happiness
it's love but wait some people can
self-sacrifice out of love in a way that
actually ends up just creating
codependency for everybody
um or okay so so how do we think about
all those things together
one like this kind of came to me as a
a simple way that i kind of relate to it
is
that a meaningful life involves the mode
of being
the mode of doing and the mode of
becoming and it involves a virtuous
relationship between those three and
that any of those modes on their own
also have failure modes that are not a
meaningful life
the mode of being the way i would
describe it
if if we're talking about the essence of
it
is about taking in and appreciating the
beauty of life that is now
it's a mode that is in the moment and
that is
largely about being with what is
it's fundamentally grounded in the
nature of experience and the
meaningfulness of experience
the prima facie meaningfulness of when
i'm having this experience
i'm not actually asking what the meaning
of life is i'm actually full of it i'm
full of experiencing it the momentary
experience yes
so taking in the beauty of life doing
is adding to the beauty of life i'm
going to produce some art i'm going to
produce some technology that will make
life easier more beautiful for somebody
else
i'm going to
do some science that will end up leading
to better insights or others people's
ability to appreciate the beauty of life
more because they understand more about
it or whatever it is
or protect it right i'm going to protect
it in some way but that's adding to
or being in service of the beauty of
life through our doing and becoming
is getting better at both of those being
able to deepen our being which is to be
able to take in the beauty of life more
profoundly
be more moved by it touched by it
and increasing our capacity with doing
to add to the beauty of life
more and
so i hold that a meaningful life has to
be all three of those
and where they're not in conflict with
each other
ultimately it grounds in being it
grounds in the intrinsic meaningfulness
of experience
and then my doing is ultimately
something that will
be able to increase the possibility of
the quality of experience for others
and my becoming is a deepening on those
so it grounds an experience and also the
evolutionary possibility of experience
and the point is to
[Music]
oscillate between these never getting
stuck on any one yeah or i suppose
in parallel well you can't really
attention is a thing
you can only allocate attention
i want moments where i am absorbed in
the sunset and
i'm not thinking about what to do next
and then
the fullness of that can make it to
where my doing doesn't come from what's
in it for me
because i actually feel overwhelmingly
full already
and then it's like how can i how can i
make life better for other people that
don't have as much opportunities i had
how can i add something wonderful how
can i just be in the creative process
and so i think where the doing comes
from matters and if the doing comes from
a fullness of being
it's inherently going to be paying
attention to externalities
or it's more oriented to do that than if
it comes from some emptiness that is
trying to get full in some way that is
willing to cause sacrifices other places
and where a chunk of its attention is
internally focused
and so when buddha said desire is the
cause of all suffering then
later the vow of the bodhisattva which
was to show up for all sentient beings
and universe forever is a pretty intense
thing like desire
i would say there is a kind of desire if
we think of desire as a basis for
movement like a flow or a gradient
there's a kind of desire that comes from
something missing inside
seeking fulfillment of that in the world
that ends up being the cause of
actions that perpetuate suffering but
there's also not just
non-desire there's a kind of desire that
comes from feeling full
at the beauty of life and wanting to add
to it that is a flow this direction
and i don't think that is the cause of
suffering i think that is
you know and the western traditions
right the eastern traditions focused on
that
and kind of unconditional happiness
outside of them in the moment outside of
time
western tradition said no actually
desire is the source of creativity and
we're here to be
made in the image and likeness of the
creator we're here to be fundamentally
creative
but creating from where and in service
of what
creating from a sense of connection to
everything and wholeness in service of
the well-being of all of it
is very different
which is back to that compassion
conversion axis being doing becoming
is pretty powerful
also could potentially be algorithmized
into a robot just saying
where does um
where does death come to that
so being is forgetting i mean the the
concept of time completely
there's a there's a sense the doing and
becoming that has a deadline and
built in the urgency
built in do you think death is
fundamental to this
to a meaningful life uh
acknowledging or um
feeling the terror of death like ernest
becker
or just acknowledging the uncertainty
the mystery the
the melancholy nature of the fact that
the right ends
is that part of this equation or it's
not necessary okay
look at how it could be related i've
experienced fear of death
i've also experienced
times where i thought i was gonna die it
felt extremely
peaceful and beautiful and
um it's funny because
if we we can be afraid of death because
we're afraid of hell or bad
reincarnation or the bardo or some kind
of idea of the afterlife we have where
we're projecting some kind of sentient
suffering
but if we're afraid of just
non-experience
i notice that every time i stay up late
enough that i'm really tired
i'm longing for deep deep sleep and
non-experience
right like i'm actually longing for
experience to stop
and it's not morbid it's not a bummer
it's
and and i don't mind falling asleep and
i
sometimes when i wake up want to go back
into it and
then when it's done i'm happy to come
out of it so
um
when we think about death and having
finite time here
and we could talk about if we live for a
thousand years instead of a hundred or
something like that it'd still be fine
night time
the one bummer with the age we die is
that i generally find that people
mostly start to emotionally mature just
shortly before they die
but
there's
if i get to live forever i i can just
stay focused on what's in it for me
forever
and if life continues and consciousness
and sentience and
people appreciating beauty and adding to
it and becoming continues my life
doesn't but my life
can have effects that continue well
beyond it
then life with a capital l starts
mattering more to me than my life
my life gets to be a part of an in
service too
and the whole thing about when old men
plant trees the shade of which they'll
never
get to be in um i remember
the first time i read this poem by hafez
the sufi poet
written in like the 13th century or
something like that
and he talked about that if you're
lonely to think about him and he was
kind of leaning his spirit
um into yours across the distance of a
millennium
and would come for you with these poems
and now
he's thinking about people millennium
from now and caring about their
experience and what they'd be suffering
if they'd be lonely and could he offer
something that could touch them
and it's just [ __ ] beautiful and
so like the most beautiful parts of
humans have to do with something that
transcends what's in it for me
and death forces you to that so not
not only does death create the urgency
it uh
urgency of doing it you're very right it
does have a sense
in which it uh incentivizes the
compersion
and the compassion
and the widening you remember einstein
had that quote something to the effect
of it's an optical delusion of
consciousness to believe there are
separate things
there's this one thing we call universe
and uh
something about us being inside of a
prison of perception
that can only you know see a very narrow
little bit of it
but this this might be just
some weird disposition of mine but
when i think about the future after i'm
dead and i think about
consciousness i think about
young people falling in love for the
first time in their their experience and
i think about people being awed by
sunsets and i think about
all of it right i can't not feel
connected to that
do you feel some sadness
to the very high likelihood that you
will be forgotten completely by all of
human history
you daniel the name
that that which cannot be named
systems like to self-perpetuate
egos do that the idea that i might do
something meaningful that future people
appreciate of course there's like a
certain sweetness to that idea
but i know how many people did something
did things
that i wouldn't be here without that my
life would be less without whose names i
will never know
and i feel a gratitude to them i feel a
closeness i feel touched by that and i
think
to the degree that the future people are
conscious enough
there is a you know a lot of traditions
had this kind of
are we being good ancestors and respect
for the ancestors beyond the names
i think that's a very healthy idea but
let me return to a much
less beautiful and uh much less pleasant
conversation
you mentioned prison back to x-risk okay
and conditioning you mentioned something
about the state
so what role let's talk about
companies governments parents
all the mechanisms that can be a source
of conditioning
which flavor of ice cream do you like
do you think the state is the right
thing for the future so governments that
are elected democratic systems
that are representing representative
democracy
is there some kind of political system
of governance that you find appealing is
it parents
meaning a very close-knit tribes of
conditioning
that's the most essential and then uh
you and michael malus would happily
agree that it's anarchy or the state
should be
dissolved or destroyed or burned to the
ground if you're michael malus
giggling holding the torch
as the fire burns so which which is it
is the state
can the state be good or is the state
bad for the conditioning of a beautiful
world
a or b this is like an s you like tests
you like to give these uh simplified
good or bad things
um would i like the state
that we live in currently the united
states federal government to
stop existing today no i would really
not like that um
i think that would be not quite bad for
the world in a lot of ways
uh do i think that it's a
optimal social system and maximally uh
just and humane and
all those things and i wanted to
continue as is no also not that
um but i am much more interested in it
being able to evolve to a better thing
without going through um the catastrophe
phase that i think
it's just non-existence would give so
what size
a state is good in a sense like
do we should we as a human society as
this world becomes more globalized
should we be constantly striving to
reduce
the set you we can we can put on a map
like right now literally
like the the centers of power in the
world
some of them are tech companies some of
them are governments
should we be trying to as much as
possible decentralize
the power to where it's very difficult
to point on the map
the centers of power and that means
making the state however there's a bunch
of different ways to make the government
much smaller
that could be re reducing
in the united states reducing the
the funding for the government all those
kinds of things there's a set of
responsibilities
the the set of powers it could be
i mean this is far out but making
more nations or maybe nations not in the
space that are
defined by geographic location but
rather in the space of ideas
which is what anarchy is about so
anarchy is about forming collectives
based on their set of ideas
and doing so dynamically not based on
where you were born
and so on i think we can say that the
natural state of humans if we want to
describe such a thing
was to live in tribes
that were below the dunbar number
meaning that for a few hundred thousand
years of human history
all of the groups of humans mostly
stayed under that size
and whenever it would get up to that
size it would end up cleaving and so it
seems like there's a pretty strong
but there weren't individual humans out
in the wild doing really well right so
we were a group animal but with groups
that had a specific size so we could say
in a way humans were being domesticated
by those groups they were learning how
to have certain rules to participate
with the group
without which you'd get kicked out but
that that's still the wild state of
people
and and maybe it's useful to do as a
side statement
which i've recently looked at a bunch of
papers around dunbar's number
where the mean is actually 150. if you
actually look at the original papers
to range it's really a range so it's
actually
some somewhere under a thousand so it's
a range from like two to five hundred or
whatever it is
but like you could argue that the uh i
think it actually is exactly two
uh two the range is two to five hundred
and twenty something like that
and this is the mean that's taken
crudely
it's not a very good paper the the in
terms of the actual
numerical numerically speaking but
it'd be interesting if there's a bunch
of dunbar numbers
that could be computed for particular
environments particular conditions so on
it is very true that they're likely to
be something small
you know under a million but it'd be
interesting if we can expand that number
in interesting ways that will change the
fabric of this conversation i just want
to kind of throw that in there
i don't know the if the 150 is baked in
some hollow in the heart
into the hardware we can talk about some
of the things that it probably has to do
with
up to a certain number of people and
this is going to be variable based on
the social technologies that mediate it
to some degree we can talk about that
in a minute um
[Music]
up to a certain number of people
everybody can know everybody else pretty
intimately
so let's go ahead and just take 150 as a
as an average number
everybody can know everyone intimately
enough that
if your actions made anyone else do
poorly it's your extended family
and you're stuck living with them and
you know who they are and there's no
anonymous people there's no just them
and over there
and that's one part of what leads to a
kind of tribal process where it's good
for the individual and good for the
whole has a coupling
also below that scale everyone is
somewhat aware of what everybody else is
doing there's not
groups that are very siloed and as a
result
it's actually very hard to get away with
bad behavior there's a forced kind of
transparency
and so you don't need kind of like the
state
in in that way but lying to people
doesn't actually get you ahead
sociopathic behavior doesn't get you
ahead because it gets seen
and so there's a conditioning
environment where the
individuals behaving in a way that is
aligned with the interest of the tribe
is what gets conditioned when it gets to
be a much
larger system it becomes easier to
hide certain things from the group as a
whole as well as to be less emotionally
bound to a bunch of anonymous
people i would say there's also a
communication
protocol where up to about that number
of people
we could all sit around a tribal council
and be part of a conversation around a
really big decision do we migrate do we
not migrate do we you know some
something like that do we get rid of
this person
and why why would i want to
agree to be a part of a larger group
where everyone can't be part of that
council and so i am going to now be
subject to law that i have no say in if
i could be part of a smaller group that
could still survive and i get a say in
the law that i'm subject to so i think
the cleaving
and a way we can look at it beyond the
dunbar number two is we can look at that
a civilization has
binding energy that is holding them
together and has cleaving energy and if
the binding energy exceeds
the cleaving energy that civilization
will last and so there are things that
we can do to decrease the cleaving
energy within the society things we can
do to increase the binding energy i
think naturally we saw that had certain
characteristics up to a certain size
kind of tribalism
that ended with a few things it ended
with people having migrated enough that
when you started to get resource wars it
you couldn't just migrate away easily
and so tribal warfare became more
obligated
it involved the plow in the beginning of
real economic surplus there were so
there were a few different kind of
um forcing functions
but we're talking about what size should
it be right what size should a society
be and i think
the idea like if we think about your
body for
a moment as a self-organizing complex
system that is multi-scaled
we think about bodies of wonderland our
body is a wonderland yeah
uh you have that's a john mayer song i
apologize
but yes so uh if we think about our body
and the billions of cells that are in it
well you don't have like think about how
ridiculous it would be to try to have
all the tens of trillions of cells in it
with no internal organization structure
right just like a sea of protoplasm your
democracy
and so you have cells and tissues
and then you have tissues and organs and
organs and organ systems and so you have
these layers of
organization and then obviously the
individual and a tribe in a
ecosystem and each of the higher layers
are both based on the lower layers but
also influencing them
i think the future of civilization will
be similar
which is there's a level of governance
that happens at the level of the
individual
my own governance of my own choice
i think there's a level that happens at
the level of a family
we're making decisions together we're
inter-influencing each other and
affecting each other taking
responsibility
for the idea of an extended family and
you can see that like for a lot of human
history we had an extended family we had
a local community
a local church or whatever it was we had
these intermediate structures
whereas right now this kind of like the
individual
producer consumer taxpayer voter and the
massive nation state global complex
and not that much in the way of
intermediate structures that we relate
with and not that much in the way of
real personal dynamics all
impersonalized made fungible and
so i think that we have to have
global governance meaning i think we
have to have governance at the scale we
affect stuff and if
if anybody is messing up the oceans that
matters for everybody so that
that can't only be national or only
local
everyone is scared of the idea of global
governance because we think about some
top-down system of imposition that now
has no checks and balances on power i'm
scared of that same version so i'm not
talking about that kind of global
governance
um it's why i'm even using the word
governance as a process rather than
government as an imposed
uh phenomena and so i think we have to
have global governance but i think we
also have to have local governance and
there has to be
relationships between them that each
where there are both checks and balances
in power flows of information
so i think governance at the level of
cities will be a bigger
deal in the future than governance at
the level of nation-states because i
think
nation-states are largely fictitious
things
that are defined by wars and agreements
to stop wars and like that
i think cities are based on real things
that will keep being real we're the
proximity of certain things together
the physical proximity of things
together gives increased value of those
things
so you look at like jeffrey west's work
on scale and finding that
companies and nation states and things
that have a kind of complicated
agreement structure get diminishing
return
of you of production per capita as the
total number of people increases beyond
about the tribal scale but the city
actually gets
increasing productivity per capita but
it's not designed it's kind of this
organic thing right
so there should be governance at the
level of cities because people can sense
and actually have some agency there
probably neighborhoods and smaller
scales within it and also verticals
and some of it won't be geographic it'll
be network-based right networks of
affinities
so i don't think the future is one type
of governance
now what we can say more broadly is say
when we're talking about groups of
people that inter-affect each other
the idea of a civilization is that we
can figure out how to coordinate our
choice making
to not be at war with each other and
hopefully increase total
productive capacity that's good for
everybody division of labor and
specialty so we all get
more better stuff and whatever but it's
a
it's a coordination of our choice making
i think we can look at civilizations
failing on the side
of not having enough coordination of
choice making so they fail on the side
of chaos and then they cleave and an
internal war comes about or whatever
or they can't make smart decisions and
they overuse their resources or whatever
or it can fail on the side of trying to
get order
via imposition via force and so it fails
on the side of oppression which ends up
being
for a while functional ish
for the thing as a whole but miserable
for most people in it until it fails
either because of revolt or because it
can't innovate enough or something like
that
and so there's this like toggling
between
order via oppression and chaos and i
think the idea of democracy
not the way we've implemented it but the
idea of it whether we're talking about
a representative democracy or a direct
digital democracy liquid democracy uh
republic or whatever the idea of an open
society participatory governance
is can we have order that is emergent
rather than imposed
so that we aren't stuck with chaos and
infighting and inability to coordinate
and we're also not stuck with oppression
and what would it take to have emergent
order
this is the most kind of central
question for me these days
because if
we look at what different nation states
are doing around the world and we see
nation states that are more
authoritarian that in some ways are
actually coordinating much more
effectively
so for instance we can see that
china has built high-speed rail not just
through its country but around the world
and the us hasn't built any high-speed
rail yet you can see that it brought 300
million people out of poverty in a time
where
we've had increasing economic inequality
happening
you can see like that
if there was a single country that could
make all of its own stuff if the global
supply chains failed
china would be the closest one to being
able to start to go closed
loop on fundamental things uh belt and
road
initiative supply chain on rare earth
metals
transistor manufacturing that is like oh
they're actually coordinating more
effectively in some important ways
in the last call it 30 years and
that's imposed order in post order and
we can see that if in the u.s
if no let's look at why real quick
we know why we created term limits so
that we wouldn't have
forever monarchs that's the thing we
were trying to get away from and that
there would be checks and balances on
power and that kind of thing
but that also has created a negative
second order effect which is nobody
does long-term planning because somebody
comes in who's got four years they want
re-elected
they don't do anything that doesn't
create a return within four years they
will end up getting them
elected re-elected and so the 30-year
industrial development to build
high-speed trains or
the new kind of fusion energy or
whatever it is just doesn't get invested
in
and then if you have left versus right
where whatever someone does for four
years then the other guy gets in and
undoes it for four years
and most of the energy goes into
campaigning against each other this
system is just dissipating as heat
right like it's just burning up as heat
and the system that has no term limits
and no internal friction in fighting
because they got rid of those people
can actually coordinate better but
uh i would argue it has its own fail
states eventually
and dystopic properties that are not the
thing we want
so the goal is to accomplish to create a
system that does
long-term planning without the negative
effects of a monarch
or dictator that stays there for the
long term
and
accomplish that through uh not doing the
imposition
of a single leader but through uh
emergence so
it doesn't that perhaps
first of all the technology in itself
seems to me
maybe disagree allow for different
possibilities here
which is make primary the system not the
humans
so the the the basic uh the medium
on which the democracy happens like
like a platform or where people can
make decisions do the choice making
the coordination of the choice making
where emerges some kind of order to
where like something that applies at the
scale of the family the extended family
the city the the country
the the continent the whole world and
then does that so dynamically
constantly changing based on the needs
of the people sort of always evolving
and uh it would all be owned by google
like doesn't doesn't this is there a way
to um
so first of all you're optimistic that
it you could basically create like
technology can save us
technology at creating platforms by
technology i mean like software network
platforms
that allows humans to deliberate
like make government together
dynamically
without the need for a leader that's on
a podium screaming stuff
that's one and two if you're optimistic
about that
are you also optimistic about the ceos
of such platforms
the idea that technology is
values neutral values agnostic and
people can use it for constructive or
destructive purposes but it doesn't
predispose anything it's just it's just
silly and naive
technology elicits patterns of human
behavior because those who utilize it
and get ahead
end up behaving differently because of
their utilization of it and then other
people
then they end up shaping the world or
other people race to also get the power
of the
technology and so there's whole schools
of anthropology that look at the
effect on social systems and the minds
of people of the change in our tooling
marvin harris's work called cultural
materialism looked at this deeply
obviously
marshall mcluhan looked specifically at
the way that information technologies
changed the nature of our beliefs minds
values
social systems
i will not try to do this rigorously
because there are academics we'll
disagree on the subtle details but i'll
do it kind of like
illustratively you think about the
emergence of the plow the oxtron plow in
the beginning of agriculture that came
with it where before that you had hunter
gather
and then you had horticulture kind of a
digging stick but not
the plow well that the world changed a
lot with that right
and
a few of the changes that um at least
some theorists believe in
is when the oxtron plow started to
proliferate any culture that utilized it
was able to start to actually cultivate
grain because just with a digging stick
you couldn't get enough grain for it to
matter grain was a storable caloric
surplus they could make it through the
famines they could grow their population
so the ones that used it got so much
ahead that it became obligate and
everybody
used it that corresponding with the use
of a plow
animism went away everywhere that it
existed because you can't talk about the
spirit of the buffalo while beating the
cow all day long to
pull a plow so the moment that we do
animal husbandry of that kind we have to
beat the cow all day you have to say
it's just a dumb animal man has dominion
over earth and the nature of even our
religious and spiritual ideas change
you went from women primarily using the
digging stick to do the horticulture
or gathering before that men doing the
hunting stuff to now men had to use the
plow because the upper body strength
actually really mattered women would
have miscarriages when they would do it
when they were pregnant
so all the caloric supply started to
come from men where it had been from
both before
and the ratio of male female gods
changed to being mostly male gods
following that
um obviously we went from very s
that particular line of thought then
also says that feminism followed the
tractor
and that the rise of feminism um
in the west has started to follow women
being able to say we can do what men
can because the male upper body strength
wasn't differential once the internal
combustion engine was much stronger
and we can drive a tractor so i don't
think
to try to trace complex things to one
cause is a good idea so i think this is
a reductionist view but it has truth in
it
and so the idea that technology is
values agnostic is silly
technology codes patterns of behavior
that code rationalizing those patterns
of behavior and believing in them
the plow also is the beginning of the
anthropocene right it was the beginning
of us changing the environment radically
to
to clear-cut areas to just make them
useful for people which also meant the
change of the view of where the
the web of life were just a part of it
etc so all those types of things
um so that's brilliantly put but by the
way
that was just brilliant but the question
is
so it's not agnostic but so we have to
look at what the psychological effects
of specific tech applied certain ways
are
and be able to say it's not just doing
the first order thing you intended
it's doing like the effect on patriarchy
and animism
and the end of tribal culture in the
beginning of empire and the class
systems that came with that and
we can go on and on about what the plow
did um the beginning of surplus was
inheritance which then became the
capital model and like lots of things
so we have to say when we're looking at
the tech how is what are the values
built into the way the tech is being
built that are not obvious
right so you always have to consider
externalities yes and the externalities
are not just physical to the environment
they're also to how the people are being
conditioned and how the relationality
between them as being conditioned
question i'm asking you so i personally
would
rather be led by a plow and a tractor
than stalin
okay that's the question i'm asking you
is uh
in creating an emergent government
or people where there's a democracy
that's dynamic that makes
choices that does governance at
at like a very kind of liquid
like uh there's a bunch of fine
resolution layers of abstraction
of governance happening at all scales
right and doing so dynamically where no
one person has power at any one time
that can dominate
and impose rule okay that's the stalin
version
i'm saying isn't there the
uh alter the isn't the alternative
that's emergent
empowered or made possible by
the plow and the tractor which is the
modern version of that
is like the internet the the digital
space where we can
the monetary system where you have the
cryptocurrency and so on
but you have much more importantly to me
at least is just basic social
interaction the mechanisms of human
transacting with each other in the space
of ideas isn't
so yes it's not agnostic definitely not
agnostic
you've had a brilliant rant there the
tractor has effects
but isn't that the way we achieve an
emergent system
of uh governance yes but i wouldn't say
we're on track
you haven't seen anything promising yeah
i haven't seen anything promising is
that to be on track requires
understanding and guiding some of the
things differently than is currently
happening and it's possible
that's actually what i really care about
so
you couldn't have had a stalin without
having certain
technologies emerge he couldn't have
ruled such a big area without
transportation technologies without the
train without the uh communication tech
that made it possible
so when you say you'd rather have a
tractor or a plow than a stall and
there's a relationship between them that
is more recursive
which is new physical technologies
allow rulers to rule with more power
over larger distances
historically and
um but some things are more responsible
for that than others
like stalin also ate stuff for breakfast
but the thing he ate for breakfast is
less responsible for the starvation of
millions
than than the train the train is more
responsible for that
and then the weapons of war are more
responsible so some technology
like let's not throw it all in the
you're saying like
technology has a responsibility here but
some
is better than others i'm saying that
farm
people's use of technology will change
their behavior so it has behavioral
dispositions built in
the change of the behavior will also
change the values in the society
it's very complicated right it will also
as a result
both make people who have different
kinds of predispositions with regard to
rulership
and different kinds of new capacities
and so
we have to think about these things it's
kind of well
understood that the printing press and
then in
early industrialism ended feudalism and
created
kind of nation states so one thing i
would say
as a long trend that we can look at is
that whenever there is a a step function
a major leap
in technology physical technology the
the underlying techno-industrial base
with which we do stuff
it ends up coding for it ends up
predisposing a whole bunch of human
behavioral patterns that the previous
social system what had not emerged to
try to solve
and so it usually ends up breaking the
previous social systems
the way the plow broke the tribal system
the way that the industrial revolution
broke the feudal system
and then new social systems have to
emerge they can deal with that
the new powers the new dispositions
whatever with that tech
obviously the nuke broke nation-state
governance being adequate
and said we can't ever have that again
so then it created this in international
governance apparatus world
so i guess
what i'm saying is
that the solution
is not exponential tech
following the current path of what the
market incentivizes exponential tech to
do market being a previous social tech
i would say that
exponential tech
if we look at different types of social
tech so let's just briefly look at
that democracy tried to do the emergent
order thing
right at least that's the story and
which is and this is why if you look
this important um part to build first
it's kind of doing it it's just doing it
poorly you're saying i mean that's it is
emergent order in some sense i mean
that's the hope of democracy versus
other
forms of government correct i mean i i
said at least the story because
obviously it didn't do it for women and
slaves early on it doesn't die for all
classes equally et cetera
but the the idea of democracy is that
is participatory governance and so you
notice that the modern democracies
emerged
out of the european enlightenment and
specifically
because the idea that a lot of people
some huge number not a tribal number
huge number of anonymous people who
don't know each other are not
bonded to each other who believe
different things who grew up in
different ways can
all work together to make collective
decisions well that affect everybody
and where some of them will make
compromises and the thing that matters
to them for what matters to other
strangers
that's actually wild like it's a wild
idea that that would even be possible
and it was kind of the result of this
high enlightenment idea
that we could all do the philosophy of
science
and we could all do the hegelian
dialectic those ideas had emerged right
and it was
that we we could all
so our choice making because we said a
society is trying to coordinate choice
making the emergent order is the order
of our of the choices that we're making
not just the level of the individuals
but what groups of individuals
corporations nations states whatever do
our choices are based on our choice
making is based on our sense making and
our meaning making
our sense making is what do we believe
is happening in the world
and what do we believe the effects of a
particular thing would be our meaning
making us what do we care about
right our values generation what do we
care about that we're trying to move the
world in the direction of
if you ultimately are trying to move the
world in a direction that is really
really different than the direction i'm
trying to we have very different values
we're gonna have a hard time and if you
think the world is a very different
world right if you
think that systemic racism is rampant
everywhere one of the worst problems and
i think it's not even a thing
if you think climate change is almost
existential and i think it's not even a
thing
we're gonna have a really hard time
coordinating and so we have to be able
to have shared sense-making
of can we come to understand just what
is happening
together and then can we do shared
values generation okay maybe i'm
emphasizing a particular value more than
you but i can see how
i can take your perspective and i can
see how the thing that you value is
worth valuing
and i can see how it's affected by this
thing so can we take all the values and
try to come up with a proposition that
benefits all of them better
than the proposition i created just to
benefit these ones it harms the ones
that you
care about which is why you're opposing
my proposition we don't even try in the
process of crafting a proposition
currently
to see and this is a reason that the
proposition when we vote on it gets half
the votes almost all the time
it almost never gets 90 of the votes is
because it benefits some things and
harms other things
we can say all theory of trade-offs but
we didn't even try to say could we
see what everybody cares about and see
if there is a better solution
so how do we fix that try i i wonder is
it
is it as simple as the social technology
of education well no
it's that the proposition crafting and
refinement process has to be
key to a democracy or participatory
governance and it's not currently
but it's this isn't that the humans
creating that situation
so so one way there's two ways to fix
this
one is to fix the individual humans
which is the education early in life
and the second is to create somehow
systems that yeah
both so i understand the education part
but creating systems that's why that's
why i mentioned the technologies is
creating
social networks essentially yes that's
actually necessary yeah okay so let's go
to the first part and then we'll come to
the second part
so democracy emerged as an enlightenment
era idea
that we could all do a dialectic
and come to understand what other people
valued and so that we could
actually come up with a cooperative
solution rather than just
[ __ ] you we're gonna get our thing in
war right and that we could sense make
together we could all apply the
philosophy of science
and you weren't gonna stick to your guns
on what the speed of sound is if we
measured it and we found out what it was
and
there's a unifying element to the
objectivity in that way
and so this is why um i believe
jefferson said if you could give me a
perfect newspaper and a broken
government or
i'm paraphrasing or a broken government
perfect newspaper i wouldn't hesitate to
take the perfect newspaper because if
the people understand what's going on
they can make build a new government
if they don't understand what's going on
they can't possibly make good choices
and washington i'm paraphrasing again
first president said the number one aim
of the federal government
should be the comprehensive education of
every citizen in the science of
government
science of government was the term of
art think about what that means right
science of government would be
game theory coordination theory history
wouldn't call game theory yet
history sociology economics right all
the things that lead to how we
understand human coordination
i think it's so profound that he didn't
say
the number one aim of the federal
government is rule of law
and he didn't say it's protecting the
border from enemies because if the
number one aim was to protect the border
from enemies
it could do that as military
dictatorship quite effectively
and if the goal was rule of law it could
do it as a dictatorship
as a police state and so if the number
one
goal is anything other than the
comprehensive education of all the
citizens and the science of government
it won't stay a democracy long
you can see so both education and the
fourth estate
the fourth estate being the so education
can i make sense of the world am i
trained to make sense of the world the
fourth estate is what's actually going
on currently the news do i have
good unbiased information about it those
are both considered prerequisite
institutions for democracy to even be a
possibility
and then at the scale it was initially
suggested here the town hall was the key
phenomena
where there wasn't a special interest
group crafted a proposition and the
first thing i ever
saw was the proposition to know anything
about and i got to vote yes or no
it was in the town hall we all got to
talk about it and the proposition could
get crafted in real
time through the conversation which is
why there is that
founding father statement that that
voting is the death of democracy
voting fundamentally is polarizing the
population in some kind of sublimated
war
but and we'll do that as the last step
but what we want to do first is to say
how does the thing that you care about
that seems damaged by this proposition
how could that turn into a solution to
make this proposition better
where this proposition still tends to
the thing it's trying to tend to
antennas to that better can we work on
this together
in and in a town hall we could have that
as the scale increased we lost the
ability to do that
now as you mentioned the internet could
change that the fact that
we had representatives that had to ride
a horse from one town hall to the other
one to see what the colony would do
that we stopped having this kind of
developmental
um propositional development process
when the town hall ended the fact that
we have not used the internet to
recreate this is
somewhere between insane and
aligned with class interests i would
push back to say that the internet has
those things it just says a lot of other
things
i feel like the internet has places
where that encourage
synthesis of competing ideas
and sense making which is what we're
talking about
it's just that it's also flooded with a
bunch of other
systems that perhaps are out competing
it under current incentives
perhaps has to do with capitalism in the
market
linux is awesome right and wikipedia and
places where you have
and they have problems but places where
you have open source
sharing of information betting of
information towards collective building
is that building something like like
how much has that affected our court
systems or
our policing systems or our military
systems or first of all i think a lot
but not not enough i i i think that's
something i told you offline yesterday
is uh
perhaps that's a whole nother discussion
but i i don't think we're
quite quantifying the impact on the
world
of the positive impact of wikipedia
you said the policing the i mean i just
i just think the amount of um
empathy that could like knowledge
i think can't help but lead to
empathy just knowing okay
just knowing okay i'll i'll give you
some pieces of information
knowing how many people died in various
awards that already that delta
when you have millions of people have
that knowledge it's like it's a little
like slap in the face like oh
like my boyfriend or girlfriend breaking
up with me
is not such a big deal when millions of
people were tortured
you know like just a little bit and when
a lot of people know that because of
wikipedia
or the effect there's second order
effect of wikipedia which is
it's not that necessarily people read
wikipedia it's like
youtubers who don't really
know stuff that well will
thoroughly read a wikipedia article and
create a compelling video describing
that wikipedia article that then
millions of people watch and they
understand that
holy [ __ ] a lot of there was such first
of all there was such a thing as world
war ii in world war one
okay like they can at least like learn
about it
they can learn about this was like
recent they can learn about slavery they
can learn about
all kinds of injustices in the world and
that i think has
a lot of effects to our to the way
whether you're a police officer a a
lawyer a judge
in the jury or just a regular
civilian citizen the way you approach
the the uh every other communication you
engage in
even if the system of that communication
is very much flawed so i think there's a
huge positive effect on wikipedia
that's my case for wikipedia so you
should donate to wikipedia i
i'm a huge fan but there's very few
systems
like it which is sad to me so i think
it's it would be a useful exercise
for any uh listener of the show
to really try to run the dialectical
synthesis
process with regard to a topic like this
and take the
techno concern perspective with regard
to
information tech that folks like tristan
harris
take and say what are all of the things
that are getting worse
and what and are any of them following
an exponential curve and how much worse
how quickly could that be
and then and do that fully without
mitigating it
then take the techno-optimist
perspective and see what things are
getting better
in a way that kurzweil or diamandis or
someone might do
and try to take that perspective fully
and say are some of those things
exponential
what could that portend and then try to
hold all that at the same time
and i think there are
ways in which depending upon the metrics
we're looking at
things are getting worse on exponential
curves and better on exponential curves
for different metrics at the same time
which which i hold is the
destabilization
of previous system and either an
emergence to a better system or
collapse to a lower order are both
possible
and so i want my optimism not to be
about my assessment
i want my assessment to be just as
[ __ ] clear as it can be
i want my optimism to be what inspires
the solution
process on that clear assessment so i
never
i never want to apply optimism in the
sense making right i want to just
try to be clear if anything i want to
make sure that the
challenges are really well understood
but that's in service of an optimism
that
there are good potentials even if i
don't know what they are that are worth
seeking
right there's kind of a there is a some
sense of optimism that's required to
even try to innovate really hard
problems
but then i want to take my pessimism and
red team my own optimism
to see is that solution not going to
work does it have second order effects
and then knock it not get upset by that
because i
then come back to how to make it better
so just a relationship between optimism
and pessimism and the dialectic of how
they
how they can work so when i of course
we can say that wikipedia is a pretty
awesome example of
a thing we can look at the places where
it has limits or
has failed where
on a celebrity topic or corporate
interest topic you can pay wikipedia
editors to
edit more frequently and various things
like that but you can also see where
there's a lot of information
that was kind of decentrally created
that is good information that is more
easily accessible to people than
everybody buying their own encyclopedia
britannica or walking down to the
library
and they can be updated in real time
faster
and i think you're very right
that the business model is a big
difference
because wikipedia is not a for-profit
corporation
it is a it's tending to the information
commons and it doesn't have
an agenda other than tending to the
information commons
and i think the two masters issue is a
tricky one when i'm trying to optimize
for very different kinds of things um
where i have to sacrifice one for the
other and i can't find synergistic
satisfiers which one
and if i have a fiduciary responsibility
to shareholder
uh profit maximization and you know what
what does that
end up creating i think
the ad model that silicon valley took
um i think jaren lanier i don't know if
you've had him on the show but he has
interesting assessment of
the nature of the ad model um silicon
valley
wanting to support capitalism and
entrepreneurs to make things but
uh also the belief that information
should be free
and also the network dynamics with the
more people you got on you got
increased value per user per capita as
more people got on so you didn't want to
do anything to slow the rate of adoption
um some places actually you know paypal
paying people money to join the network
because the
uh value of the network would be there'd
be a metcalf-like dynamic proportional
to the square of the total number of
users
so um the ad model made sense of how do
we
make it free but also be a business get
everybody on
but not really thinking about what it
would mean to
and this is now the whole idea that if
you aren't paying for the product you
are the product um
if if they have a fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholder
maximize profit their customer is the
advertiser the user who it's being built
for is to
do behavioral mod for them for
advertisers
that's a whole different thing than that
same type of tech could have been if
applied with a different business model
or a different purpose
um i think there's
because facebook and
google and other information and
communication platforms end up
harvesting data about
user behavior that allows them to model
who the people are
in a way that gives them more sometimes
specific information
and behavioral information then
even a therapist or a doctor or a lawyer
or a priest might have in a different
setting they basically are
accessing privileged information there
should be a fiduciary responsibility
and in normal fiduciary law if there's
this principal agent thing if you are a
uh principal and i'm an agent on your
behalf i don't have a game theoretic
relationship with you right if you're
sharing something with me and i'm the
priest or i'm the therapist i'm never
going to use that information to try to
sell you a used car or
whatever the thing is but facebook is
gathering
massive amounts of privileged
information and using it to modify
people's behavior for a behavior that
they
didn't sign up for wanting the behavior
but what the corporation did
so i think this is an example of the
physical tech evolving in the context of
the previous social tech
where it's being shaped in particular
ways and here unlike wikipedia that
evolved for the
the information commons this evolved for
fulfilling particular agenda purpose
most people when they're on facebook
think it's just a tool that they're
using they don't realize it's an agent
right it is a corporation with a profit
motive and
um and as i'm interacting with it it has
a goal for me different than my goal for
myself
and i might want to be on for a short
period of time its goal is maximize time
on site
and so there is a rivalry that is take
but where there should be a fiduciary
contract
i think that's actually a huge deal and
i think if we said could we apply
facebook like technology
to
develop people's citizenry capacity
right to develop
their personal health and well-being and
habits as well as their
um cognitive understanding the
complexity with which they can process
the health of their relationships
that would be amazing to start to
explore and this is now the thesis that
we started to discuss
before is every time there is a major
step function in the physical tech
it obsoletes the previous social tech
and the new social tech has to emerge
what i would say is that when we look at
the nation-state level of the world
today
the more top-down authoritarian nation
states are
as the exponential text started to
emerge the digital technology started to
emerge
they were in a position for better
long-term planning
and better coordination and so the
authoritarian state started applying the
exponential tech
intentionally to make more effective
authoritarian states
and that's everything from like an
internet of things surveillance system
going into machine learning systems to
the sesame credit system to all those
types of things
and so they're upgrading their social
tech using the exponential tech
otherwise within a nation state like the
us but
democratic open societies the sus the
countries the states are not
directing the technology in a way that
makes a better open society meaning
better emergent order
they're saying well the corporations are
doing that and the state is doing
the relatively little thing it would do
aligned with the previous corporate law
that no longer is relevant because there
wasn't fiduciary responsibility for
things like that there wasn't anti-trust
because this creates functional
monopolies because of network dynamics
right where youtube has
more users than vimeo and every other
video player together amazon has a
bigger percentage of market share than
all of the other markets together
you get one big dog per vertical
because of network effect which is a
kind of organic monopoly that the
previous anti-trust law didn't even have
a place
that wasn't a thing anti-monopoly was
only something that emerged in the space
of government contracts
so um so what we see is the new
exponential technology is being directed
by authoritarian nation states to make
better authoritarian nation states and
by corporations to make more powerful
corporations
the more powerful corporations when we
think about the scottish enlightenment
when the idea of markets was being
advanced the modern kind of ideas of
markets
the biggest corporation was tiny
compared to what the biggest corporation
today is so the asymmetry of it relative
to people was tiny
and the asymmetry now in terms of the
total technology it employs total amount
of money total amount of information
processing
is so many orders of magnitude and
rather than there be demand for an
authentic thing
that creates a basis for supply as
supply started to get way more
coordinated and powerful and the demand
wasn't coordinated because you don't
have a labor union of all the customers
working together
but you do have a coordination on the
supply side supply started to recognize
that it could manufacture demand
it could make people want [ __ ] that they
didn't want before that maybe wouldn't
increase their happiness
in a meaningful way might increase
addiction addiction is a very good way
to manufacture demand
and so as soon as manufactured demand
started
through this is the cool thing and you
have to have it for status or whatever
it is
the intelligence of the market was
breaking now it's no longer collective
intelligence system that is up
regulating
real desire for things that are really
meaningful you're able to hijack
the lower angels of our nature rather
than the higher ones the addictive
patterns
drive those and have people watch it
that doesn't actually make them happier
make the world better
and so we really also have to we have to
update our theory of markets because
behavioral econ showed that homo
economicus the rational actor is not
really a thing
but particularly at greater and greater
scale can't really be a thing
voluntarism isn't a thing where if my
corp if my company doesn't want to
advertise on facebook i just will lose
to the companies that do because that's
where all the [ __ ] attention is
and so then i can say it's voluntary but
it's not really if there's a functional
monopoly
same if i'm going to sell on amazon or
things like that so
what i would say is these corporations
are becoming
more powerful than nation states in some
ways
and
they are also debasing the integrity
of the nation states the open societies
so the democracies are getting weaker
as a result of exponential tech and the
kind of new
tech companies that are kind of a new
feudalism tech feudalism because
it's not a democracy inside of a tech
company or the supply and demand
relationship
when you have manufactured demand and
kind of monopoly type functions
and so we have basically a new feudalism
controlling exponential tech and
authoritarian nation states controlling
it and those attractors are both shitty
and so i'm interested in the application
of exponential tech
to making better social tech that makes
emergent order possible and
where then that emergent order can bind
and direct the exponential tech
in fundamentally healthy not x-risk
oriented directions
i think the relationship of social tech
and physical tech can make it
i think we can actually use the physical
tech to make better social tech but it's
not
given that we do if we don't make better
social tech
then i think the physical tech empowers
really shitty social tech that it's not
a world that we want
i don't know if it's a road we want to
go down but i tend to believe that the
market will create
exactly the thing you're talking about
which i feel like there's a lot of money
to be made
in creating a
social tech that creates a better
citizen
it creates a better human being
the this this uh the the your
description of facebook and so on
which is a system that creates addiction
which manufacturers demand
is not obviously inherently
the consequence of the markets like i
feel like that's the the first stage of
us
like baby deer trying to figure out how
to use the internet
i feel like there's much more money to
be made with something that
creates compersion
and love honestly i mean i i really
from we can have this i can make the
business case for it i don't know
i don't think we want to really have
that discussion but don't do you have
some hope that that's the case and
what i guess if not then how do we fix
the system of markets that work so well
for
the united states for so long like i
said every social tech worked for a
while like tribalism worked
well for two or three hundred thousand
years i think
social tech has to keep evolving the
social technologies
with which we organize and coordinate
our behavior
have to keep evolving as our physical
tech does
so i think the thing that we call
markets
of course we can try to say oh even
biology runs on markets and
but the thing that we call markets
the underlying theory homo economicus
demand driving supply that thing broke
it broke with scale in particular um
and a few other things so it needs
updated in a really fundamental
way um i think there's something even
deeper than making money happening
that it in some ways will obsolete money
making
i think capitalism is not about business
so if you think about business i'm going
to produce a good or a service that
people want and
bring it to the market so that people
get access to that good or service
that's the world of business
but that's not capitalism capitalism is
the
management and allocation of capital
which
financial services was a tiny percentage
of the total market has become a huge
percentage of the total market it's a
different creature
so if i was in business and i was
producing a good or service and i was
saving up enough money that i started to
be able to invest that money and gain
interest or
do things like that i could start
realizing i'm making more money
on my money than i'm making on producing
the goods and services so i stop even
paying attention to goods and services
and start paying attention to
making money on money and how do i
utilize capital to create more capital
and capital gives me more optionality
because i can buy anything with it than
a particular good or service that only
some people want
capitalism
more capital ended up meaning more
control
i could put more people under my
employment i could buy larger pieces of
land novel access to resource mines and
put more technology under my employment
so it meant increased agency and also
increased control
i think attentionalism is even more
powerful
so rather than enslave people
where the people kind of always want to
get away and put in
the least work they can there's a way in
which economic servitude was just more
profitable than slavery
right have the people work even harder
voluntarily because they want to get
ahead
and nobody has to be there to whip them
or control them or whatever
[Music]
this is a a cynical take but a
meaningful take
um so people
so capital ends up being a way to
influence human behavior right
and yet where people still feel free
in some meaningful way they they're not
feeling like
uh they're going to be punished by the
state if they don't do something it's
like punished by the market
via homelessness or something but the
market is this invisible thing i can't
put an agent on so it feels like free
and so if
if you want to affect people's behavior
and still have them feel free capital
ends up being a way to
do that but i think affecting their
attention is even deeper
because if i can affect their attention
i can
both affect what they want and what they
believe and what they feel
and we statistically know this very
clearly facebook has done studies that
based on
changing the feed it can change beliefs
emotional dispositions et cetera
and so i think there's a way that the
the harvest and directing of attention
is even a more powerful system than
capitalism it is
effective in capitalism to generate
capital but i think it also generates
influence beyond what capital can do
and so do we want to have
some groups utilizing
that type of tech to direct other
people's attention if so
um towards what
towards what metrics of what a good
civilization and good human life would
be
what's the oversight process what is the
transparency i can i can
answer all the things you're mentioning
uh i i can build i guarantee you if i
i'm not such a lazy ass uh i'll be part
of the many people doing this
as transparency and control like to
giving control to individual people okay
so maybe
the corporation has
coordination on its goals that all of
its customers or users together don't
have so there's some asymmetry where
it's
uh asymmetry of its goals but maybe i
could actually help
all of the customers to coordinate
almost like a labor union or whatever by
informing and educating them adequately
about the effects the externalities on
them this is not toxic waste going into
the ocean of the atmosphere it's their
their minds their beings their families
their relationships
um such that they will in group change
their
behavior and um i think
the idea one way of saying what you're
saying i think is that you think that
you can rescue
homo economicus from
uh the rational actor that will pursue
all the goods and services and choose
the best one at the best price the kind
of rand
one misses hayek that you can rescue
that from dan ariely and behavioral econ
that says that's actually not how people
make choices they make it based on
status hacking
largely whether it's good for them or
not in the long term
and the large asymmetric corporation can
run
propaganda in narrative warfare that
hits people's status buttons and their
limbic hijacks and their lots of other
things in ways that
they can't even perceive that are
happening um they're not paying
attention to that this site is employing
psychologists and split testing and
whatever else
so you're saying i think we can recover
homo economics
and not just through a singles like
mechanism technology there's there's the
uh not to keep mentioning the guy but
platforms like
joe rogan and so on that that make
help make viral the ways
that the education of negative
externalities can become viral
in this world so interestingly
i actually agree with you that
got them that we four and a half hours
in
that we can tech can do some good all
right
well see what you're talking about is
the application of tech here broadcast
tech where you can speak to a lot of
people and that's not going to be
strong enough because the different
people need spoken too differently which
means it has to be different voices that
get amplified to those audiences more
like facebook's tech
but nonetheless we'll start with
broadcast tech plants the first seed and
then the word of mouth
is a powerful thing you need to do the
first broadcast shotgun and then
it like lands so catapulted whatever i
don't know what the right weapon is
but then it just spreads to word of
mouth through all kinds of tech
including facebook so let's come back to
the fundamental
thing the fundamental thing is we want
to kind of order at various scales
from the conflicting parts of our self
actually
having more harmony than they might have
to uh family extended family local
all the way up to global we want
emergent order where our
choices have
more alignment right we want
that to be emergent rather than imposed
or rather than we want fundamentally
different things or make totally
different sense of the world where
warfare of some kind becomes the only
solution
emerging order requires us in our choice
making requires us being able to
have related sense making and related
meaning making processes
can we apply digital
technologies and exponential tech in
general to try to
increase the capacity to do that where
the technology called a town hall the
social tech that we all get together and
talk obviously is very scale limited
and it's also oriented to geography
rather than networks of aligned interest
can we build new better versions of
those types of things
and going back to the idea that a
democracy or participatory governance
depends upon comprehensive education in
the science of government which includes
being able to understand things like
asymmetric information warfare on the
side of governments and how the people
can
organize adequately can you utilize some
of the technologies now
to be able to support increased
comprehensive education
of the people and maybe comprehensive
informedness
so both fixing the decay in both
education and the fourth estate that
have happened so the people can start
self-organizing to then
influence the corporations the nation
states
to do different things and or build new
ones themselves
yeah fundamentally that's the thing that
has to happen we
the exponential tech gives us a novel
problem landscape that the world never
had
the nuke gave us a novel problem
landscape and so that required
this whole bretton woods world the
exponential tech gives us novel problem
landscape
our existing problem-solving processes
aren't doing a good job
we have had more countries get nukes we
haven't nuclear d proliferation we
haven't achieved any of the un's
sustainable development goals
we haven't kept any of the new
categories of tech for making arms races
so our global coordination is not
adequate to the problem landscape
so we need fundamentally better problem
solving processes a market or a state is
a problem-solving process we need better
ones it can do
the speed and scale of the current
issues right now speed is one of the
other big things
is that by the time we regulated ddt out
of existence or
cigarettes not for people under 18
they'd already killed so many people and
we
let the market do the thing but as elon
has made the point that won't work for
ai by the time we recognize
afterwards that we have an autopoetic ai
that's a problem you won't be able to
reverse it that there's a number of
things that
when you're dealing with tech that is
either self-replicating
and disintermediates humans to keep
going doesn't need humans to keep going
or you have tech that just has
exponentially fast effects
your regulation has to come early it
can't come
after the effects have happened the
negative effects have happened
if because the negative x could be too
big too quickly so we basically need new
problem solving processes that do
better at being able to internalize
externality
solve the problems on the right time
scale and the right geographic
scale and those new processes to not be
imposed have to emerge from people
wanting them
and being able to participate in their
development which is what i would call
kind of a new cultural enlightenment or
renaissance that has to happen
where people start understanding the new
power
that exponential tech offers the way
that it is actually damaging
current governance structures that we
care about
and creating an x-risk landscape but
could also be redirected
towards more protopic purposes and then
saying how do we rebuild new social
institutions what are adequate social
institutions where we can do
participatory governance at scale and
time
and how can the people actually
participate to build those things
i the the solution that i see working
requires a process like that
and the result maximizes love so
again elon musk that love is the answer
let me take it back from the scale of
societies
to the scale that's far far more
important which is the uh
scale of uh family you've written a blog
post about your dad
we have uh various flavors of
relationships with our
fathers uh what have you learned
about life from your dad
well people can read the blog post and
see
a lot of individual things that i
learned that i really appreciated
if i was to kind of summarize at a high
level
um i had a really incredible dad like
very very unusually uh positive set of
experiences
he was committed we were homeschooled
and he was committed to work from home
to be available
and like prioritize fathering in a
really deep way
and you know as a super gifted super
loving very unique man he also had his
unique issues that were part of what
crafted the unique brilliance and those
things often go together
and i say that because i think i had
i had some unusual gifts and also some
unusual difficulties
and i think it's useful for everybody to
know their path probably has both of
those
um but uh
if i was to say kind of at the essence
of one of the things my dad taught me
across a lot of lessons was like
a the intersection of self-empowerment
ideas and practices that
self-empower towards collective good
uh towards some virtuous purpose beyond
the self
and he both said that a million
different ways taught it in a million
different ways when we were doing
construction and he was teaching me how
to
build a house we were putting the wires
to the walls before the drywall went on
he made sure that
the way that we put the wires through
was beautiful like the
the that the
height of the holes was similar that we
twisted the wires in a particular way
that
and it's like no one's ever going to see
it and he's like if a job's worth doing
it's worth doing well and excellence is
its own reward and those types of ideas
and if there was a really shitty job to
do he'd say see the job do the job stay
out of the misery just don't indulge any
negativity do the things that need done
and so there's like a there's an
empowerment and a nobility
together um and
yeah extraordinarily fortunate
is there ways you think you could have
been a better son
is there things you regret it's an
interesting question
let me first say just as a bit of a
criticism
that uh what kind of man do you think
you are
not wearing a suit and tie a real man
should
exactly uh i agree with your dad at that
point you mentioned offline that uh he
suggested
a real man should wear a suit and tie
but outside of that is there ways you
could have been a better son
maybe next time on your show i'll wear a
suit and tie
my dad would be happy about that um
please
i can answer the question later in life
not early
um i had just a huge amount of respect
and reverence for my dad when i was
young so i was asking myself that
question
a lot so i learned a lot of things i
knew that i
wasn't seeking to apply um
there was a phase when i went through my
kind of individuation differentiation
where i had to make him excessively
wrong about too many things
um i don't think i had to but i did and
he had a lot of kind of non-standard
model beliefs about things
whether early
uh kind of ancient civilizations or
ideas on evolutionary theory or
alternate models of physics and
and um and
they weren't irrational but they didn't
all have the standard of
epistemic proof that i would need and
i went through and some of them were
kind of spiritual
ideas as well i went through a phase in
my early 20s
where
i kind of had the the attitude that
dawkins
or christopher hitchens has that can
kind of be um
like excessively certain and
sanctimonious
uh applying their reductionist
philosophy of science to everything and
um kind of brutally dismissive
uh i'm embarrassed by that phase
not to say anything about those men in
their path but
for myself and so during that time
i was more dismissive of my dad's
epistemology
than i would have liked to have been i
gotta correct that later
apologize for it but that's the first
thought that came to mind
you've written the following i've had
the
experience countless times making love
watching a sunset listening to music
feeling the breeze that i would sign up
for this
whole life and all of its pains just to
experience
this exact moment this is a kind of
worldless knowing
it's the most important and real truth i
know that experience itself
is infinitely meaningful and pain
is temporary and seen clearly
even the suffering is filled with beauty
i have experienced
countless lives worth of moments worthy
of life
such an unreasonable fortune
a few words of gratitude from you
beautifully written
is there some beautiful moments now you
have uh
experienced countless lives worth of
those moments
was there some things that um if you
could uh
in your darker moments you can go to to
relive to remind yourself that the whole
ride is worthwhile
maybe skip the making love part we don't
i know about that
i mean i i feel i feel unreasonably
fortunate that
it is a such a humongous list
because i mean i feel fortunate to have
like had exposure to practices and
philosophies and way of seeing things
that makes me see things that way
so i can take responsibility for seeing
things in that way
and not taking for granted really
wonderful things but i can't take
credit for being exposed to the
philosophies that even gave me that
possibility
um you know it's not just
with my wife it's with
every person who i really love when
we're talking i look at their face
i in the context of a conversation feel
overwhelmed by
how lucky i am to get to know them and
like that there's never been someone
like them in all of history
and there never will be again and they
might be gone tomorrow i might be gone
tomorrow and like i get this moment with
them
and when you take in the uniqueness of
that fully and the beauty of it it's
overwhelmingly beautiful
and i remember the first time
i did a big dose of mushrooms and
i was looking at a tree for a long time
and i was just crying with overwhelming
how beautiful the tree was and it was a
tree outside the front of my house that
i'd walk by a million times and never
looked at like this and it wasn't the
dose
of mushrooms where i was hallucinating
like where the tree was purple yeah like
the tree still looked like
if i had to describe it says green it
has leaves looks like this
but it's way [ __ ] more beautiful like
like capturing than it normally was and
i'm like why is it so beautiful if i
would describe it the same way
and i realized i had no thoughts taking
me anywhere else
yeah like what it seemed like the
mushrooms were doing was just actually
shutting the narrative off that would
have me be distracted so i could really
see the tree
and then i'm like [ __ ] when i get off
these mushrooms i'm going to practice
seeing the tree
because it's always that beautiful and i
just miss it and so i
practice being with it and quieting the
rest of the mind and then being like wow
and and if it's not mushrooms like
people have peak experiences
where they'll see life and how
incredible it is it's always there
it's funny that i had this exact same
experience
on quite a lot of mushrooms just sitting
alone and looking at a tree and exactly
as you described it
appreciating the undistorted beauty of
it
and it's funny to me that here's two
humans very different with very
different journeys
or at some moment in time both looking
at a tree like idiots for hours
and just in awe and and happy to be
alive in the end
even just that moment alone is is worth
living for but you did say
humans and uh we have a moment together
as two humans
and you mentioned shots well i have to
ask what uh what
what are we looking at when i went to go
get a smoothie before coming here i got
you a keto smoothie that you didn't want
because you're not just keto but fasting
but i saw the thing with you and your
dad where you did uh
shots together yeah and this place
happened to have shots
of um ginger turmeric cayenne
juice of some kind and so i was some
himalayan i didn't necessarily plan it
for being on the show
i just brought it wow but we can we can
do it that way i think we should we
shall uh
we shall toast like heroes daniel
it's a huge host what do we toast to we
toast to this moment
this this this unique moment that we get
to share together
i'm very grateful to be here in this
moment with you and uh
yeah i'm grateful that you invited me
here we met for the first time
and i will never be the same for the
good and the bad
the i am
that is really interesting that feels
way healthier than the vodka
my dad and i were drinking so i feel
like a better man already daniel this is
one of the best conversations i've ever
had
i can't wait to have many more likewise
this is uh
it's been an amazing experience thank
you for wasting all your time today i
want to say
in terms of what you're mentioning about
like the
that you work in machine learning and
the
optimism that wants to look at the
issues but wants to
look at how this increased technological
power could be applied to solving them
and that even thinking about the
broadcast of like
can i help people understand the issues
better and help organize them
like fundamentally you're you're
oriented like wikipedia
what i see to really try to tend to the
information commons
without another agentic interest
distorting it
and for you to be able to get guys like
lee smallin and roger penrose and like
the the greatest thinkers of
that are alive and you know have them on
the show
and most people would never be exposed
to them and talk about it in a way that
people can understand
uh i think it's an incredible service i
think you're doing great work
so i was really happy to hear from you
thank you daniel
thanks for listening to this
conversation with daniel schmokenberger
and thank you to
ground news netsuite four sigmatic
magic spoon and better help check them
out in the description
to support this podcast and now let me
leave you with some words
from albert einstein i know not with
what weapons world war 3 will be fought
but world war 4 will be fought with
sticks and stones
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you